İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 28 Şubat 2025 Cuma günü saat 19.30. 67. ders günümüz.
Dersimize başlıyoruz. Bu arada herkesin ne dilerim Ramazan ayı hayırlı olsun.
Oruç döneminde başlıyor.
Nerede kaldığımızı şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Atomik işlemlerdeydik.
Atomic operations.
Konkurrensi başlığı altında belki de en önemli konulardan biri atomik operations, atomik işlemler.
Bir işlemin atomik olması ne demek?
Önce bundan bahsettik. Şöyle biraz toparlayalım.
Bir işlemin arkadaşlar atomik olması bölünemez olması demek.
Yani araya bir işlem girmeyecek.
Mesela normalde bir değişkeni atomik olmayan bir değişkeni değerini değiştirmek.
Bir İngilizce'de read, modify, write işlemi.
Burada read ile modify, modify ile write arasına başka bir trade'in bir işlemi girebilir.
Ama eğer arkadaşlar işlem atomik ise bu zaten garanti altına alınıyor.
Dolayısıyla atomik işlemler, atomik değişkenler üstünde yapılıyor.
İşte programlama dillerinin, farklı farklı programlama dillerinin standart kütüphanelerinin bu atomik işlemlerle ya da atomik işlemlerin üstünde yapıldığı atomik değişkenlerle ilgili standart kütüphanelerin verdiği destek ya da destekler var.
Bizim standart kütüphanemizde de bu destek atomik header'ı içindeki sınıflar ve fonksiyonlar idi.
Arkadaşlar sonra neyi gördük?
Şöyle bir akışı hatırlayalım.
Evet.
Biraz bekleteceğim.
Arkadaşlar aslında atomik bir template.
Fakat bu template'in neleri var?
Specialization'ları var.
Şöyle biz kendimiz yazalım en iyisi.
Yani atomik sınıf şablonunun, atomik sınıf şablonunun örneğin int açılımı.
Atomik sınıf şablonunun örneğin arkadaşlar int yıldız açılımı.
Bir pointer türü olabilir.
Efendim bir primitive türü olabilir.
Bir tam sayı türü, bir gerçek sayı türü olabilir.
Standart kütüphane bunlar için ya explicit ya da partial specialization'lar veriyor.
Bu da ne demek?
Şimdi template olması yanıltmasın.
Aslında bir master template var.
Ama bir de özelleştirilmiş full specialization ya da partial specialization'lar var.
Bu da şu demek, interfeyslere aynı olmak zorunda değil.
Öyle değil mi?
Ortada tek bir template olsaydı, bir explicit specialization ya da partial specialization olsaydı,
bütün specialization'ların interfeysi aynı olacaktı.
Fakat burada interfeys aynı olmak zorunda değil.
Zaten ilerleyen dakikalarda da tekrar ona bakacağız.
Arkadaşlar şimdi atomik işlemlerin bizi ilgilendiren birden fazla ne diyelim özelliği var.
Birincisi o açık, bölünemez.
Yani atomik işlem hangi atomik değişken üstünde yapılırsa yapılsın bölünemez.
Arkadaşlar ama işlemin bölünemezliğiyle işlemlerin sıralanması,
İngilizcesiyle ordering farklı şeyler.
İşte atomik değişkenlerin kullanımı aynı zamanda işlemlerin sıralanmasıyla ilgili
ve dolayısıyla senkronize edilmesiyle ilgili de bir takım garantiler veriyor.
Biz geçen dersimizde bir giriş yaptık ama o garantilerden bahsetmedik.
Yani bir atomik değişkeni örneğin sadece onun üstünde yapılan işlemler bölünemez olduğu için
veri yarışı, data race'i engellemek için kullanabiliriz.
Fakat bunun yanında aynı zamanda bir senkronizasyon mekanizması olarak da kullanabiliriz.
Geçen dersimizde bu senkronizasyonla ilgisini göstermedik.
Ama bu derste göreceğiz.
İşte burada önemli, biraz da zor bir kavram karşımıza çıkacak.
Memory oradır.
Birazdan bundan bahsetmeye başlayacağız.
Şimdi atomik türlerden arkadaşlar bir ayrı bir tür vardı.
Onu gördük.
Atomic flag.
Onunla dedik atomik sınıf şablonunun buğul açılımını birbiriyle karıştırmayalım.
Arkadaşlar şimdi atomik specialization'ın hangi açılımları için hangi işlemler var onları bir göstermek istiyorum.
Ama madem karşıma hazırladığım bu sayfa çıktığı Yostis'in kitabından hemen buna da değineyim.
Belirli specialization'lar için bu template notasyonunu kullanmak yerine bunlara verilen type areas, türeş isimleri de var.
Örneğin atomik template'inin buğul açılımı demek yerine atomik underscore buğul type def ismini, türeş ismini kullanabilirsiniz.
Örneğin atomik unsigned int açılımı yerine atomik uint type def ismini kullanabilirsiniz.
Ya da işte görüyorsunuz arkadaşlar atomik long long yerine atomik l-l long type def ismini kullanabilirsiniz.
Burada şunu karıştırmayalım, atomik buğul başka, atomik flag başka, atomik flag'i görmüştük.
Arkadaşlar şimdi önce şu sayfaya bakalım.
Şimdi burası önemli, zaten üstünden de geçeceğiz.
Hocam sitattan önce olduğu için mi?
Tam anlayamadım Resul soruyu.
Şimdi sitat başka, türeş ismi başka.
Sitat hemen eğer soruyu yanlış anlamışsam lütfen tekrar düzeltmemi sağlayın.
Şimdi ikisi arasındaki fark çok önemli.
Sitat, konstruktora gönderilen argümanlardan template parametresine karşılık gelen template argümanının anlaşılması sentaks özelliği.
Yani örneğin template, sadece standart kütüphane için geçer değil.
Student class, my class.
Efendim public.
Arkadaşlar, my class.
İzleyin.
P, P.
My class.
P.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
E şimdi ben yukarıdaki sınıf şalmonunda normalde şöyle yazmalıyım değil mi?
My class'ın int açılımı.
Örneğin x.
Ama şimdi,
geleceğim oraya Resul.
Ben bir bitireyim.
Evet, örneğin ben şöyle yazarsam.
Derleyici 9. satırda bildirilen konstruktör nedeniyle konstruktör'a gönderilen argüman int türden olduğu için template parametresi t'ye karşılık gelen template argümanını int olarak alıyor bu sitat.
Ve sitat, sürekli tekrar ettik, c++ 17 standartıyla direklendi.
Yalnız arkadaşlar, bu konuyla ilgili önemli bir konu daha var.
Ama biraz ileri bir konu olduğu için, biraz da detay bir konu olduğu için, biraz da bizim zamanımızın kısıtlı olduğu için bu kursta anlatmadım.
Bir de Didaction Guide denilen yine bir bildirim var.
Jenerik kodlara ilişkin, sınıflara ilişkin.
Yani, birebir Türkçe'ye çevirirsek, Didaction'ın nasıl yapılması gerektiğini anlatan bir kılavuz gibi bu kursta hiç bahsetmedik.
Evet, şimdi atomik konusuna gelirsek, şimdi şöyle bir bakalım, bir tekneğimde tekrar etmiş oluruz.
Arkadaşlar, bu template işte atomik int açılımı görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Ama, az önceki resme geri dönelim.
Şuradaydı.
Evet, bakın, atomik int, atomik int açılımının türeş ismi.
Yani, böyle yazmakla, arkadaşlar, böyle yazmak arasında fark yok.
Bunun sitatla alakası yok.
Çünkü artık zaten böyle yazarak, template argümanının int olduğunu söylemiştik.
Evet.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Yani, Constructor'a gönderdiğiniz argümandan, template argümanının anlaşılmasını istiyorsanız,
sitattan faydalanmış oluyorsunuz.
Ama, ben şöyle yazmak yerine, bu specialization'a karşılık gelen türeş ismini kullanayım diyorsanız,
o zaman da, bu type alias'ı kullanıyorsunuz.
Şimdi, devam edelim.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi, bu resim bence önemli.
Burada neyi görüyoruz?
Burada, atomik operasyonların,
yok, burası değil, özür dilerim.
Biraz karıştı.
Evet, arkadaşlar, şu düzgün bir şey bulamadım.
Evet, tamam, buydu, aradım.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi, burada atomik operasyonların hangi türler için interfezde yer aldığı tablosu.
Mesela, test and set ve clear, bunları görmüştük.
Atomic flag türünde var.
Diğer atomik türlerde yok.
Mesela, is lock free, bütün atomik açılımlarında var.
Tabloyu görüyoruz, değil mi?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar, yani burada ne demek istiyor?
Atomi'in boğul açılımı,
use of define tür açılımı,
atomik pointer açılımı,
atomik herhangi bir tam sayı türü açılımı.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar, is lock free,
görüyorsunuz hepsinde var.
Load, hepsinde var.
Store, hepsinde var.
Exchange, hepsinde var.
Compare Exchange Strong, arkadaşlar,
gördüğünüz gibi,
atomic pool, atomic user type,
atomic pointer, atomic integral'de var.
Aynı şekilde compare exchange with.
Ama fetch at,
atomic pointer'da ve
atomik tam sayı türlerinde var.
Fetch, subtract,
yani bu sub,
arkadaşlar,
görüyorsunuz,
sadece,
yine özür dileyen,
fetch sub da pointer aritmetine
uygun olduğu için,
o da hem pointer açılımlarında,
hem de tam sayı açılımlarında var.
Ama,
arkadaşlar,
bitsel veya,
bitsel özel veya,
bitsel ve eşit işlemleri,
sadece atomik'in int,
integral,
yani int türlerinden açılımları için var.
Art, artı ve eksi eksi,
yine hem pointer açılımları,
hem de,
arkadaşlar,
efendim,
tam sayı açılımları için var.
Arkadaşlar,
bu ne demek?
Bakın,
bunu fiilen bir görelim.
mesela,
atomik,
boğul açılımı türünden,
x.
Şimdi,
zaten yardımcı araç gösteriyor.
Bakın,
store'u var,
load'u var,
is lock price'i var,
exchange'i var,
compare exchange,
tronk'u,
v2 ve exchange'i var.
Ama,
atomik örneğin,
arkadaşlar,
int yıldız.
şimdi,
arkadaşlar,
görüyorsunuz,
store, load,
is lock free exchange,
patch add de var burada.
Görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Ve,
patch sub da var.
Bunlar,
artı eşit,
eksi eşit,
işlemlerinin,
adeta,
isimlendirilmiş hali.
Bunların hepsini,
bugün göstereceğim.
Fakat,
tabii en karmaşık olan,
geçen dersimizde de orada kalmıştık,
compare exchange,
strong işlemi,
yani,
TAS işlemi.
Arkadaşlar,
evet,
compare and swap deniyordu.
Buradaki,
is always lock free,
bu,
statik veri elemanı,
bu üye fonksiyon değil.
Evet.
Ama bakın,
en geniş interfeiste sahip olan,
atomik,
tam sayı türü açılımları.
Şimdi bakalım,
arkadaşlar,
compare exchange,
strong,
weak,
exchange,
patch add,
patch end,
patch or,
patch sub,
patch exor,
is always lock free,
is lock free,
load,
notify all,
buna değinmeyeceğim,
bunlar C++ 20 ile geldi.
Notify one,
operator int,
operator bitsel ve eşit,
operator artı artı,
hem önek hem son ek,
operator artı eşit,
operator eksi eşit,
operator eşit,
operatör,
bitsel özel ve ya eşit,
ve ya eşit,
store,
weight,
yine C++ 20 ile geldi,
onu anlatmayacağım demiştim.
Şimdi burada,
kritik noktalara yavaş yavaş gelelim.
Arkadaşlar,
bu operasyonların aslında her biri için,
mesela herhangi bir fonksiyonu çağıralım,
store,
dikkat ederseniz,
şöyle bir gösterelim arkadaşlar,
bunun,
bir overloadu,
bizden aslında,
memory order dediğimiz,
değeri istiyor.
İşte biz,
geçen dersimizde memory order'a hiç değinmedik,
bugünkü dersimizin konusu.
Aslında,
ben örneğin,
store fonksiyonunu bu şekilde çağırırsam,
yine o memory order denilen değeri belirlemiş oluyorum,
ama bu durumda o memory order değeri,
ilerleyen dakikalarda göreceğimiz,
memory order,
sequential consistency dediğimiz değer bulacak.
Yani aslında,
bu atomik işlemlerin hepsi için,
bir memory order parametresi var aslında.
Bu parametreye karşılık gelen bir argüman sunmazsanız,
aslında orada,
o farklı memory order kategorilerini ifade eden değerlerden,
memory order sequential consistency değerini seçmiş oluyoruz.
Ama biz oraya daha gelmedik.
Memory order'ın ne olduğunu henüz konuşmadık,
biraz daha konuşmayacağız.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi en basit işlemlerden başlayalım.
Store demek,
değişkene değer atamak demek.
Yani atomik değişkenin değerini değiştirmek için,
store fonksiyonunu çağırabilirsiniz.
Yalnız bir şeye dikkat edin,
store fonksiyonu,
geri dönüş değerini göstermek istiyorum.
Arkadaşlar,
bu void fonksiyon.
Bu işlem atomik olarak yapılıyor.
Yani bölünemez bir şekilde yapılıyor.
Arkadaşlar,
diyeceksiniz ki,
Necat şöyle bir atomo operatör fonksiyonu da var.
Evet,
böyle bir atomo operatör fonksiyonu da var.
Aslında,
x'in,
geçen dersimizde işte buralarda kalmıştık.
Atomo operatör fonksiyonuna,
argüman olarak 5 geçmekle,
aslında bu fonksiyonu,
şu bakın,
x,
operatör,
atama,
ve,
operatör,
atama,
ve bu fonksiyona,
işte,
diyelim ki,
5 değerini geçiyorum.
Arada,
bir tane önemli fark var.
Biri,
store'un void fonksiyonu olması,
ama atomo operatör fonksiyonunun,
bize,
atanan değeri,
ama referans olarak değil.
Kopyalama olarak,
yani geri dönüş değeri,
aslında,
normal konvensyon,
atomik dışında,
referans döndürmesidir.
Arkadaşlar,
yıldız dizi,
ama burada öyle değil.
Fakat,
ikinci bir özellik daha var.
Eğer bu,
aslında sadece,
atama operatörüyle ilgili değil,
bütün iş atama operatörleri için,
yani ben,
x eşit,
de deseydim,
x artı eşit,
arkadaşlar,
x eksi eşit,
de deseydim,
takip etmeniz lütfen,
x efendim,
bitsel ve eşit de deseydim,
tamam,
bu işlemlerin hepsi atomik,
hepsinin geri dönüş değeri,
atamadan sonraki,
yıldız dizinin değeri,
ama,
bunların,
memory order,
parametresi yok,
dolayısıyla,
ama bu işlemlerin,
hepsi için bir memory order,
ne diyelim,
seçimi gerekiyor,
işte burada,
memory order,
yine,
sequential consistency,
ilerleyen dakikalarda,
o sequential consistency,
ne demek,
genel olarak,
memory orderları,
inceleyeceğiz,
anlaşıldı değil mi,
yani,
atomik değişkenin,
değerini,
şu biçimlerden,
herhangi bir şekilde,
değiştirebilirsiniz,
atama yapabilirsiniz,
işlemli atama operatörünü,
kullanabilirsiniz,
mesela,
x artı eşitleri bir,
arkadaşlar,
yalnız bakın,
çok sık yapılan bir hata var,
normalde,
x artı eşit bir ile,
x eşit,
x artı bir,
aynı şeydir,
değil mi,
atomik olmayan türler için,
bunların arasında,
bir fark yok,
ama bakın,
atomik türler için,
böyle değil,
neden,
tahmin ediniz,
atomik türler için,
böyle değil,
bu arada,
Alihan'ın sorusu,
yaygın kullanım,
türeş isimleri ile olan mı,
hayır,
gerçekten de,
türeş isimleri,
tuhaf bir şekilde,
daha az kullanılıyor,
bravo,
önce toplama operatörü ile,
işlem yapıyorsunuz,
ben,
toplama işleminin,
atomik olduğunu,
söylemedim ki,
zaten,
ilerleyen dakikalarda,
buna yönelik bir örnek yapacağım,
bakın,
burada,
arkadaşlar,
o,
uninterruptible,
ya da,
undivisible olması,
burada söz konusu,
ama burada,
öyle bir şey söz konusu değil,
burada aslında,
iki tane ayrı işlem var,
ama burada bu işlem,
atomik olarak yapılıyor,
anlaşıldı,
değil mi,
şimdi burada,
bizi ilgilendiren,
fonksiyonlardan biri,
arkadaşlar,
strong,
store fonksiyonu,
uzun derece basit,
değeri değiştiriyor,
ama,
exchange fonksiyonu,
bakın,
x'in exchange fonksiyonu,
dikkat ederseniz,
bizden,
arkadaşlar,
set edilecek değeri istiyor,
buna İngilizce'de,
tipik,
topik olarak,
desired deniyor,
yani istenen değer,
ama bir de,
memory order parametresi var,
arkadaşlar,
ama geri dönüş değeri de,
set işleminden önceki değer,
yani örneğin biz,
şöyle bir,
atomik nesne oluştursaydık,
auto,
val eşittir,
arkadaşlar,
efendim,
x nokta,
exchange,
deseydik,
99,
x'in değerini,
99 yapıyoruz,
ama,
geri dönüş değeri de,
değeri,
99 olmadan,
önceki,
değer,
yani,
45,
şimdi ben,
val'in değerini yazdırdığım zaman,
görün,
bir de,
x'in değerini yazdırayım,
yaz burada bakın,
çok önemli bir nokta daha var,
Oğuzhan,
x atomik bir değişken,
peki,
nasıl oluyor da ben,
x'i,
bu şekilde kullanıp,
x'in değerini yazdırabiliyorum,
geçen dersi hatırlayın,
normalde,
x'in değerini elde etmem için,
benim,
load fonksiyonunu çağırmam lazım,
yani,
load adı üstünde,
değeri yüklüyor,
değeri alıyor,
peki,
nasıl oluyor da,
ben,
burada x'i kullandığımda,
adeta,
load etkisi yapıyor,
bravo,
tür dönüştürme,
operatör fonksiyonu var,
yani,
atomik'in,
int açılımının,
değil mi artık,
burada Türkçe'nin,
doğaflığı,
İngilizce ismi,
Türkçeleştirdiğimiz için,
atomik'in,
arkadaşlar,
int açılımının,
operatör int fonksiyonu var,
atomik'in,
long açılımının,
operatör,
long fonksiyonu var,
dolayısıyla,
x'in kendisini,
bu şekilde kullanmak,
uygun bağlamda,
yani,
bu tür dönüşümünü,
gerektiren bir bağlamda,
ile,
load fonksiyonunu,
çağırmak,
aynı şey,
ama,
yine arada aslında,
bir fark var,
yine,
aradaki fark ne,
tahmin edin,
yine,
memory order,
demekten iyi kastediyorum,
evet,
şimdi,
load'un,
memory order,
parametrisi var,
mesela,
ben load'u,
arkadaşlar,
şöyle çağırabilirim,
stut,
memory order,
diyelim ki,
ne olsun,
o gayrı,
ama,
tür dönüştürme operatör,
fonksiyonunda,
böyle bir parametre alma imkanı,
olmadığına göre,
memory order'lardan,
birini kullanıyor,
hep işte,
bu tür durumlarda,
default memory order,
her zaman,
memory order,
sequential consistency,
ya da consistent,
peki,
exchange'i de gördük,
arkadaşlar,
önce şu fonksiyonları bir bitirelim,
en zor olanı,
compare exchange,
strong'ı,
en sona bırakacağız,
arkadaşlar,
işte bu,
isminde,
patch geçenler,
patch add,
patch end,
patch or,
patch sub,
bunların her biri,
atama operatörlerinden,
aslında,
birinin karşılığı,
değil mi?
Yani örneğin,
x artı eşit,
while yazmakla,
arkadaşlar,
x,
şöyle göstereyim,
patch add,
efendim,
while yazmak,
aynı anlamda.
Yine aynı şekilde,
mesela bu,
eksi eşit olsaydı,
bu da,
patch,
sabah karşılık gelecekti.
Efendim,
bu,
bitsel v eşit olsaydı,
patch,
end eşit olacaktı.
Efendim,
bu,
Necati anladık.
Yalnız bir şeye dikkat.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın,
toplama çıkarma var,
ama,
patch,
div,
multiply diye,
bir fonksiyon yok.
Bu da önemli,
niçin önemli olduğunu,
birazdan göreceğiz.
Yine o zaman,
örneğin,
şöyle bir soru sorulsaydı bize,
x artı eşit,
while ile,
while,
bir uygun ifade,
arkadaşlar,
x,
patch add,
while arasında,
fark nedir diye sorulsaydı,
bunun yine,
arkadaşlar,
bakın,
patch add'i,
bir göstereyim,
x,
patch,
add,
izleyin,
3,
isminde,
patch geçen fonksiyonlar,
hep eski değeri get ediyor,
arkadaşlar,
yeni değeri,
yani,
arttırıyor,
set ediyor,
mesela,
patch add 3,
diyelim ki,
x'in değeri 45'si,
x'in değerini 48 yapacak,
ama,
geri dönüş değeri,
yine 45 olacak,
yani,
içinde,
patch geçenlerin,
hepsinin ortak özelliği,
eski değeri,
get etmesi,
ama,
atama operatörlerinin,
ürettiği değer,
dolayısıyla,
orada,
çarpılan fonksiyonların,
geri dönüş değeri,
nesneye,
yüklenen değer,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
evet,
peki,
şimdi,
patch'leri de geçtik,
geriye kaldı,
şu fonksiyonlar,
izleyin,
arkadaşlar,
is lock free,
load,
onu gördük,
bir de,
işte,
meşhur,
compare exchange,
strong fonksiyonu,
arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
önce,
compare exchange strong'a,
bir geri dönelim,
bunun nasıl bir işlem olduğunu,
tekrar hatırlayalım,
diyelim ki,
atomic,
int,
şimdi,
recusing,
direktifini kullanıyorum,
atomic,
int,
x,
on,
sadece izleyin,
ya da şöyle,
sitat,
şimdi,
bakınız,
izleyin,
x,
compare exchange strong,
iki tane parametre var,
birinci parametrenin referans olduğuna dikkat edin,
l value referans,
yani,
örneğin ben,
int,
expected,
arkadaşlar,
eşittir,
20,
bu değişkeni fonksiyonun birinci parametresine göndersem,
x,
expected özür dilerim,
expected,
efendim,
ikinci parametresine de,
ne bileyim,
99 değerini göndersem,
şimdi,
geri dönüş değerinde,
bir,
bull değişkeni de tutsam,
fotoyu özellikle kullanmıyorum,
siz görün diye,
şimdi izleyin,
iki tane ihtimal var,
biri,
bu işlem atomik olarak yapıldığında,
expected'ın değeri,
arkadaşlar,
atomik değişkenin değerine eşit,
yani atomik değişkenin değeri,
örneğin burada zaten 20,
ama bu burada değil değil mi,
eğer,
expected değeri ise,
önce onu göstereyim isterseniz,
10,
bu durumda,
x'in değerini,
desired olarak değiştiriyor,
buradaki terminolojisi de hep aynı,
expected,
ben değişkenimin ismini öyle yaptım,
hatta şöyle göstereyim,
daha da güzel olsun,
int,
desired,
eşitti,
arkadaşlar,
20,
şimdi bakınız,
atomik değişkenin değeri 10,
expected 10,
desired 20,
eşit mi,
expected ile atomik değişkenimizin değeri eşit,
o zaman,
set işlemi başarılı olacak mı,
olacak,
bu işlemden sonra,
x'imizin değeri ne olacak,
99 olacak,
ve fonksiyon,
true değer dönecek,
şimdi,
tek tek bir yazdırmak istiyorum,
arkadaşlar,
önce,
result'un değerini yazdırayım,
burayı anlamamız çok önemli,
biraz karmaşık bir konu çünkü,
evet,
önce rizaltın değerini yazdırıyorum,
tabi burada gördüğümüz gibi,
rizaltın değeri,
arkadaşlar,
true,
ikinci olarak,
benim atomik değişkenimin değerini yazdırıyorum,
x eşittir,
x,
atomik değişkenimin değeri ne olacak,
bu durumda,
değeri değişecek,
99 olacak,
ve expected değişkenimin değeri de değişmeyecek,
arkadaşlar,
onu da yazdıralım,
expected,
yani beklenen,
umulan anlamında,
görüyoruz,
expected'in değeri de,
yine 10,
arkadaşlar,
ama şimdi durumu değiştirelim,
ve expected'in değerini,
ne yapalım,
7 yapalım,
bu durumda,
atomik değişkenimizin değeri 10,
ama expected 7,
eşit değil,
bu durumda,
bir kere fonksiyon,
false dönecek,
buraya dikkat,
değişkenimizin değeri set edilmeyecek,
fakat,
expected değişkenine,
bu atomik değişkenimizin,
arkadaşlar,
değeri yazılacak,
şimdi aradaki parka bakın,
izleyin,
arkadaşlar,
bakın,
result false,
x'in değeri,
yine 10,
değişmedi,
ama expected'in değeri 10 oldu,
yani eğer,
expected'la,
atomik değişkenimizin değeri,
farklıysa,
compare exchange strong fonksiyonu,
bizim,
referans semantiğiyle,
fonksiyonun birinci parametresine,
geçtiğimiz,
arkadaşlar,
değişkene,
atomik değişkenin,
değerini yazıyor,
ve atomik değişkenin,
değerini,
değiştirmiyor,
arkadaşlar,
bakın,
şimdi bu,
C++,
camiasının,
yine böyle,
önemli,
tiplerinden,
konferans konuşmalarında,
falan,
görmüşsünüzdür,
P4,
şöyle yazayım ki,
derlenmeyecek çünkü,
bir sunumunda,
açık bir şekilde,
şöyle gösteriyor,
diyor ki,
compare exchange,
strong,
aslında şöyle bir işlem,
T türünden,
bunun bir template olduğunu düşünün,
herhangi bir tür,
expected,
T türünden,
design,
bu işlem,
sanki,
tabi böyle aslında değil,
sanki bir kilit varmış gibi yapılıyor,
atomik olduğunu göstermek için,
ama bakın,
atomik değişkenin,
buradaki value,
atomik değişkenimizin değeri,
ne oluyor,
arkadaşlar,
eğer,
expected'a eşit değilse,
expected'ın,
değerini,
atomik değişkenimizin,
değeri yapıyor,
ve false dönüyor,
ama değişkenin değeri,
expected'sa,
görüyorsunuz,
value burada,
atomik,
yani,
this of value anlamında,
bu sonuçta,
üye fonksiyon,
desire't yapıyor,
ve true dönüyor,
burayı anladık mı,
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki,
başlangıçta,
bu ne işe yarar,
bir kere şurası açık,
arkadaşlar,
örneğin,
ben,
belirli bir koşul oluştuğunda,
sadece,
atomik değişkenimin,
değerini değiştirmek istiyorsam,
yani örneğin,
atomikin,
int açılımı,
x,
12,
arkadaşlar,
efendim,
x'in değeri,
şu değerse,
x'in değerini,
bu değer yapmak istiyorsam,
böyle bir if deyimine ihtiyacım var,
if,
x,
compare exchange strong,
arkadaşlar,
expected,
int,
e diyelim,
eşittir,
5,
e,
ve,
diyelim ki,
10,
eğer işte,
bu koşul doğruysa,
yani,
true dönerse,
demek ki,
benim,
bu noktada,
trade'in çalışmasında,
atomik değişkenimin,
değeri,
5'miş,
ve onu,
10 yaptığımdan eminim,
ifin doğru kısmına,
girmiyorsa,
demek ki,
benim,
10'u okuduğum noktada,
onun değeri,
ne değilmiş,
arkadaşlar,
5,
değilmiş,
fakat,
asıl kritik nokta,
burası değil,
arkadaşlar,
asıl kritik nokta,
şu,
bakın,
şimdi ben sizden,
şöyle bir şey istesem,
atomik bir değişkeniniz var,
buraya dikkat,
atomik değişkenin,
değerini,
5 katına çıkarın,
yani,
12 ise,
arkadaşlar,
60 yapacaksınız,
20 ise,
100 yapacaksınız,
o zaman,
tabii,
değerin ne olduğunda,
bilmiyorsunuz,
şöyle bir şey yazmanız,
gerekir,
değil mi,
int,
diyelim ki,
val,
eşittir,
x'in load'u,
arkadaşlar,
ondan sonra,
söyleyin,
x,
store,
kaç,
efendim,
1,
çarpı 5,
hatta,
isterseniz,
şöyle yapan,
intemp,
ya da,
belki zaten,
atomik değişken değil,
x,
store,
1,
çarpı,
5,
böyle bir işlem yaptığınızı düşünelim,
arkadaşlar,
şimdi şöyle bir şey olabilir,
değil mi,
bu load'la,
store arasına,
buraya dikkat,
ayrı bir thread'in,
bir işlemi gelse,
o valin değerini,
değiştirse,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
özür dilerim,
atomik değişkenin,
değerini değiştirse,
bu durumda,
sizin yaptığınız işlemin,
lojik yapısı açısından,
en son değeri neyse,
onun 5 katına çıkartmanız gerekir,
ama şimdi diyelim ki,
x'in değeri 12 iken,
eğer araya herhangi bir thread girmezse,
x'in değeri 60 olacak,
öyle değil mi,
ama araya bir thread girdi,
atomik değişkenin değerini değiştirdi,
bakınız bu işlem atomik,
bu işlem atomik,
ama,
bu ikisi birden atomik değil ki,
burada,
araya bir thread girdi,
ve,
x'in değerini,
diyelim ki,
20 yaptı,
bu durumda,
bizim yaptığımız store işlemi,
x'in değerini 60 değil,
ne yapması gerekir,
100 yapması gerekir,
arkadaşlar,
basit bir problem gibi görünüyor ama,
bu atomik değişkenler de,
en çok veri yapılarında kullanılıyor,
lock free veri yapılarında,
orada bu büyük önem kazanacak,
yani,
eğer işte böyle araya bir thread girerse,
siz bir pointerı,
dandling pointer olarak kullanabilirsiniz,
efendim,
düğümü eklediğiniz düğüm,
eklenmemiş olabilir,
vs.
burayı anladık mı,
şimdi soru,
peki,
ne olacak da,
ben,
araya başka bir thread girse dahi,
buraya dikkat,
ne olacak ki,
ben,
araya başka bir thread girse dahi,
burada,
arkadaşlar,
değişkenimin,
değerini,
eski değerinin,
örneğin,
iki katı yaptığıma,
emin olayım,
hocam,
atomik değişkenlere,
critical section gibi bakmak lazım,
o zaten açık,
yani,
atomik değişken üstünde,
bir işlem yapılırken,
atomik bir işlem yapılırken,
araya başka bir şey giremiyor,
ama şimdi artık onu geçtik zaten,
anlaşıldı değil mi,
o zaten garanti,
ilerleyen dakikalarda,
göreceğiz,
arkadaşlar bakın,
şöyle bir kod yazsam,
önce,
ben bu değişkenin değerini,
get etsem,
mesela,
auto,
arkadaşlar,
old value,
eşittir,
x'in load'u,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
evet,
şimdi buraya şöyle bir döngü koysam,
while,
birazdan yazacağım kodu,
hemen kavramakta zorluk çekeceksiniz,
o yüzden dikkatli izlemeniz gerekiyor,
ama hemen,
anlamadım diye üzülmeyin,
burada da şöyle bir şey arasın,
x'in,
arkadaşlar,
compare exchange strong,
old value,
ve,
diyelim ki,
arkadaşlar,
old value,
çarpı,
2,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
evet,
arkadaşlar,
döngünün gövdesini,
özellikle null statement yaptım,
şu var döngüsünü,
bir adam akıllı inceleyelim,
bir kere,
bu ifade yanlış olduğu sürece dönen bir döngü değil mi?
kesinlikle,
bu ifade yanlış olduğu sürece dönen bir döngü,
o zaman bu ifade yanlış olduğu sürece,
aslında benim atomik değişkenimin değeri değişmemiş demektir,
çünkü değişseydi,
yani atomik değişkenimin değerini,
old value çarpı 2 yapsa,
yapmış olsaydı,
yiğit,
o zaman zaten true dönecekti değil mi?
herkes takip ediyor mu?
ama çok önemli bir şey var,
o da şu,
bu işlem atomik olarak yapılıyor bir,
ikincisi,
eğer expected'ın değeri,
bakın,
expected'ın değeri,
atomik değişkenin değerine eşit değilse,
expected'a neyi yazıyordu?
atomik değişkenin değerini yazıyordu,
o zaman diyelim ki,
atomik değişkenin araya bir thread girdi,
atomik değişkenin değerini 20 yaptı,
o zaman başarısız olduktan sonra,
arkadaşlar,
başarısız olduktan sonra,
bu değişkenin değeri,
izleyin,
arkadaşlar,
bu durumda 20 olacak değil mi?
o zaman döngünün bir sonraki,
ve post dönecek,
döngünün bir sonraki turunda,
atomik değişkenimizin değeri,
halen 20 ise,
o zaman,
bu set işlemi,
onun değerini 40 yapacak,
old value eşittir,
x nokta load demem gerekmiyor,
zaten kredit noktada orayı anlamanız,
çünkü compare exchange strong fonksiyonu,
zaten set işlemi yapılmadığında,
o sizin load dediğiniz değeri,
zaten old value'ya yazıyor,
şimdi anladınız mı?
herkes bir kere baksın,
biraz gerçekten,
bu atomik işlemlerle,
ilk tanıştığımızda,
hep tuhaf geliyor bu,
kas işlemi,
arkadaşlar,
gördüğümüz gibi,
aslında burada,
ben ne garantisini,
elde etmiş oluyorum,
bu atomik işlem yapıldığında,
bir önceki atomik işlemle,
araya başka bir threadin,
örneğin bir atomik işlemi girse dahi,
yani benim atomik değişkenimin değeri değişse dahi,
ben,
arkadaşlar,
o değişmiş değer üstünden,
bu işlemi yapacağım,
yapmış olacağım,
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Peki,
arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
bu compare exchange,
strong ile ilgili,
geçen yazdığımız,
spinlock'u,
bu sefer,
compare exchange,
strong ile,
implement ettim,
ve,
o koda bir bakalım,
şimdi bakın,
yine spinlock,
neydi spinlock?
Hocam,
bu while döngüsü,
maksimum iki defa mı döner,
araya başka bir thread girmez ise,
bakalım,
soruyu anlamaya çalışayım.
Araya başka bir thread girmezse,
arkadaşlar,
x'in değeri,
bu old value,
eğer değişmemişse,
zaten,
bu döngünün gövdesine,
bir kere bile girmeyecek,
hemen döngüden çıkacak.
ama değişmişse,
old value yazılacak.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Araya başka bir thread girse dahi,
zaten yine,
biz bu sefer,
old value,
x'in değeri,
otomik değişkenin değeri,
değişse dahi,
yine onu yazmış oluyoruz,
birinci parametre değişkenine,
geçtiğimiz nesneye.
nesneye.
Evet,
şimdi bakalım,
tekrar,
buraya geri döneyim,
biraz bekleteceğim.
Arkadaşlar,
bazı kodlarının,
üstünden çok hızlı geçeceğim,
çünkü,
vakit problemi var.
Bakın,
yine,
burada,
bizim bir,
atomik değişkenimiz var,
flag,
post değeriyle başlıyor,
aslında,
lag fonksiyonu,
önce,
expected,
değişkeninin,
değerini,
false yapıyor.
Arkadaşlar,
takip edin.
Ve,
compare action strong'u,
çağırarak,
onun değerini,
true yapmaya çalışıyor.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Arkadaşlar,
o zaman,
eğer,
true yapamadıysa,
tekrar false yapıyor.
O zaman,
şimdi,
söyleyin bakalım,
diyelim ki,
tahmin edin,
burada,
false olması,
kilidin alınabileceği,
anlamına geliyor,
değil mi?
Bizim flag değişkenimizin,
yani,
şu değişkenimizin,
flag'in.
Takip edin,
arkadaşlar.
Evet,
o zaman,
flag değişkeni,
bu döngüden çıkması için,
arkadaşlar,
true yapması lazım.
True yaptığı zaman,
döngüden çıkacak.
E,
true yaptığı zaman,
döngüden çıkacağına göre,
o zaman,
false değeriyle gelenler,
burada,
sürekli,
dönecek.
Çünkü,
hiçbir zaman eşit olmayacak.
Ne zamanki,
unlock fonksiyonu,
çağrılacak.
Unlock fonksiyonu,
flag değişkenimizin,
değerini,
tekrar false yapacak.
O zaman,
herhangi bir thread,
bizim spin lock'ımızın,
lock fonksiyonunu,
çağırdığında,
o zaman,
tekrar,
bu flag değişkeni,
false olduğu için,
onu,
true yapma şansı,
elde edecek.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın,
gerçi,
buraya da yazmışım,
false olması,
unlocked,
true olması,
locked.
Biraz karmaşık gibi görünüyor.
Zaten bu kodlar,
dedim ya,
biraz zihinsel,
açıdan karmaşık geliyor her zaman.
ama bir alıcı gözüyle bakıp,
spin lock'ın,
lock fonksiyonunun,
arkadaşlar,
kilidi nasıl,
kilitlediğini,
nasıl kilidi aldığını,
anlamaya çalışın.
Burada,
biz flag değişkenimizin,
değerini,
true yapabilmemiz için,
bir önceki değerinin,
false olması lazım.
bir önceki değerin,
false olması,
zaten kilidin,
boşta olması demek,
unlocked olması demek.
O zaman,
herhangi bir noktada,
eğer ben onu,
false olarak yakalarsam,
ve,
bu döngüde,
sürekli spin atacağım,
sürekli spin atacağım.
Yani,
false olduğu için,
true olduğu için,
buradan çıkamayacak.
ama ne zamanki,
arkadaşlar,
tekrar,
false'dayken,
burada yakalarsa,
bu döngüden çıkacak,
vekili de,
sahip olacak.
Anlock'ta,
tekrar,
sınıfın,
veri elemanından,
statik veri elemanı olan,
flag'i,
false değere çekecek.
Arkadaşlar,
dikkat ederseniz,
burada,
daha önceki örnekte,
olduğu gibi,
atomic flag'de de,
bunu yapmıştık.
Birini yok,
thread'in bloke olması,
söz konusu değil.
Sürekli,
arkadaşlar,
bu programın,
akışı,
thread'i buraya geldiğinde,
sürekli aslında,
burada,
bizim,
lag fonksiyonu,
flag'in,
compare'e,
strong fonksiyonunu çağırıyor.
Arkadaşlar,
gerçekten,
bir bug var mı,
yok mu,
onu göstermek için,
bir tane,
shared data oluşturdum.
Inktur'dan,
değeri sıfır.
10.000 kez dönen,
bir döngü görüyorsunuz.
Döngünün,
her turunda,
spin lag,
şu global değişkeni mi,
arkadaşlar,
bu da,
adeta bir mutex değil mi?
Önce,
lag fonksiyonunu çağırarak,
kilitledim.
Kilit altında,
shared data'yı arttırdım.
Bakın,
eğer programın,
akışı buradaysa,
buraya gelen,
bütün thread'ler,
lag fonksiyonunu çağırdığımda,
o zaman,
lag fonksiyonu,
arkadaşlar,
burada,
dönmeye,
devam ediyor.
Dolayısıyla,
onların beklemesi demek,
aslında,
bu döngünün,
sürekli,
çalışması demek.
Beşerit data'yı arttırdıktan sonra,
an lag fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum.
Eğer bakın,
herhangi bir,
eğer,
hediyelim,
bug varsa,
tabii o da garanti değil,
başka durumlar da olabilir,
yeni bizi yanıltabilir.
Ama en azından,
buradaki kod çalıştığında,
Necati,
buradaki kod ne?
10 tane thread oluşturdum.
10 thread data,
yukarıdaki increment,
shared data fonksiyonunu çağırdım.
O zaman,
10 çarpı,
10 bin,
100 bin olması lazım.
Evet,
takip edin.
görüyorsunuz,
shared data,
arkadaşlar,
100 bin.
Peki,
şimdi biz,
compare exchange strong'ı,
öğrendik.
Arkadaşlar,
compare exchange weak,
daha az çağırdığımız bir fonksiyon,
ama neyle ilgili?
Aradaki fark şu,
bakınız.
Şimdi ben,
şöyle bir kod yazsam,
izleyin,
atomic,
int,
yukarıdaki kod da sileyim artık,
geçti hükmü.
Şöyle bir kod yazsam,
atomic,
int,
x,
on,
ve,
az önceki örnekle olduğu gibi,
buraya bir deyimi koysam,
x,
compare,
exchange,
strong,
efendim işte,
int,
expected,
eşittir,
on,
expected,
sadece beni izleyin,
ve,
arkadaşlar,
efendim,
ne diyelim,
20.
Şimdi sadece soruyu anlamaya çalışın.
İpin doğru kısmına girmişse,
compare exchange strong,
pro değer döndürmüştür.
Bu durumda,
artık atomik değişkenimizin,
değerinin değiştiğinden eminiz.
Yani if'in doğru kısmında biz,
atomik değişkenin değerinin,
değiştiğini varsayarak,
işimizi yapabiliriz.
Buraya kadar tamam mı?
Fakat şimdi,
izleyin,
host dönmesi demek,
aslında,
expected'in değerinin,
x'in değerine,
eşit olmaması demek.
Öyle değil mi?
işte bakın,
compared exchange week'de,
şöyle bir problem var.
Yine,
spurious wake up vardı ya,
adeta oradaki gibi.
Arkadaşlar,
burada,
false dönse dahi,
aslında,
ya da şöyle diyelim,
expected'in değeri,
atomik'in değerine eşit olsa dahi,
yine fonksiyon ne dönebiliyor?
False dönebiliyor.
Normalde,
true dönmesi lazım değil mi?
İşte bu da,
arkadaşlar,
spurious değer değişikliği,
sahte değer değişikliği,
artık ne derseniz.
İşte,
bu da şu demek,
eğer,
böyle bir ihtimal yoksa,
çalıştığınız sistemde,
doğrudan bunu kullanabilirsiniz.
ya da,
bunu kullanıp,
bunu döngüsel bir yapı içinde,
kullanabilirsiniz.
Yani,
diyelim ki,
değerin illa değişmesi gerekiyor,
eşit olması durumunda.
Yine,
homebillere exchange week'i kullanın.
Ama,
bunu,
bir döngü içinde kullanın.
Arkadaşlar,
bu kadar.
Aradaki fark,
bu.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
atomik değişkenlerin,
kullanımı üstünde,
bir iki tane kod daha inceleyeceğiz.
Fakat,
ondan sonra,
şu,
memory order konusuna gireceğiz.
Yani,
asıl bizi zorlayacak olan,
doğrusu isterseniz,
memory order konusu.
Ama şimdi,
şuna bakın,
çok güzel bir kod.
Arkadaşlar,
bir counter sınıfı oluşturdum.
Fakat,
counter sınıfı,
atomic counter.
Yani,
ben,
normalde,
intürden bir değişkeni,
counter olarak kullansaydım,
burada,
birden fa,
hatta,
onu bir daha gösterelim.
Bakın,
atomic counter değil,
normal,
counter yapıyorum.
Takip edin.
Bu fonksiyonu,
bir milyon kez dönüyor.
Arkadaşlar,
biraz bekleteceğim.
bu fonksiyonu,
bir milyon kez dönüyor.
10 tane thread çalıştırıyorum.
Ve,
10 tane thread de,
yine,
değerinin,
10 milyon olması gerekiyor.
Değil mi?
Hatta,
hatta,
biraz belki daha güzel kod.
İzleyin.
Şimdi,
daha da güzel bir kod yazacağım.
Sorumunu test edeceğiz.
void var.
Arkadaşlar,
bu döngü de,
1 milyonmuş bu arada,
1 milyon kez dönüyor.
fakat burada da,
eksi eksi count var.
Şimdi soru,
ben,
şunu,
20 yapsam,
arkadaşlar,
ben şöyle bir kod yazsam,
for,
i eşittir,
0,
i küçük,
20,
artı artı i,
oraya da bir if koysam,
if,
i mod 2,
arkadaşlar,
e,
a köşeli parantez,
i,
eşittir,
stu thread,
biri fu,
biri var değil mi?
u,
çeğitir et,
as,
h köşeli parantez,
i,
çeğitir et,
var.
Şimdi yavaş yavaş gidiyorum.
Bu,
hüküme parantezini sildim.
şu nest scope'tan sonra,
j-thread nesnelerin destraktörü,
threadleri join etti.
Ve ben,
arkadaşlar,
global değişken olan,
cnt'nin değerini,
sıfırla başlayacak ama,
yazdırayım.
cnt eşittir,
cnt.
burada tabi ki,
data race var.
İzleyin.
Evet arkadaşlar,
burada bakın,
data race olduğu için,
sıfır değil.
Mesela ben bunu,
atomik değişken yapsaydım,
atomic int,
eğer kodda herhangi bir hata yapmadıysam,
arkadaşlar,
kesinlikle ne olması gerekir?
Değerin,
sıfır olması gerekir,
değil mi?
Görüyor musunuz?
Neden sıfır oldu?
E,
çünkü işlemler atomik olduğu için,
data race olmadı.
Evet,
işte 5 tane thread,
1 milyon kere arttırırken,
5 tane thread de,
1 milyon kere eksiltti.
Sonuçta,
sıfır oldu.
Bunu neden söyledim?
Yukarıdaki kodu,
şöyle test edeceğim şimdi.
İzleyin.
Bu sefer,
değişkenim,
atomic counter türünden olacak.
Zaten,
default constructorı,
görüyorsunuz.
VL elemanı olan,
atomic inti,
sıfır değeriyle başlatıyor.
Şimdi,
sınıfın interface'ine bakalım.
Arkadaşlar,
operatör artı artı,
bu,
önek artı artı,
operatörü,
MC'nin değerini bir arttırıyor,
ve artmış değeri döndürüyor.
Efendim,
son ek artı artı operatörü,
yine,
bizim atomik değişkenimizin,
değerini bir arttırıyor,
arkadaşlar,
ama eski değerini döndürüyor.
Eksi ekse,
açıklamaya gerek yok.
get fonksiyonu da,
aslında,
load fonksiyonunu çağırıyor,
atomik değişkenin.
Operatör int fonksiyonu da,
işte bakın,
az önce,
normal,
atomik sınıfının da,
operatör int fonksiyonu vardı ya,
efendim,
operatör int fonksiyonu da,
yine,
load fonksiyonunu çağırıyor.
Burada tabii,
arkadaşlar,
return,
MC'de diyebilirim.
Şimdi,
o zaman,
bu sefer,
kodda,
yine hiçbir,
sentaks hatası yok,
ama ilginç bir şekilde.
Neden?
Çünkü,
aslında,
cnt,
bu sınıf türünden,
ama,
sınıfın artı artı operatörü var,
eksi ekse operatörü var.
Üstelik,
operatör,
int fonksiyonu da olduğu için,
burada da,
int'e,
dönüşecek.
O zaman,
yine,
eğer bir problem yoksa,
sıfır olması gerekecek.
Bir.
Evet.
Görüyorsunuz,
değil mi?
İşlemlerin,
atomik olarak yapılmasının,
ne anlama geldiğini,
göstermek için.
Arkadaşlar,
biraz da şundan,
bahsedelim.
Neyin?
Pointer açılımı.
neden Pointer açılımına,
bu kadar önem veriyoruz?
Çünkü,
veri yapılarında,
arkadaşlar,
özellikle bu,
lock-free,
veri yapılarında,
yani,
hiç mutex,
doğrudan,
kullanmadan,
oluşturulan,
ama,
thread safe olan,
data race oluşturmayan,
veri yapılarında,
tipik olarak,
Pointer'ın,
atomik olması gerekiyor.
İşte,
bizim standart kötü bahanemiz,
bu yüzden,
atomik sınıfının,
Pointer specialization'ı da veriyor.
Hatta,
hatta,
C++,
arkadaşlar,
20 ile birlikte,
yanlış söylemeyeyim,
20-23,
bazen karıştırıyorum,
20 tabii,
atomik sınıfının,
Shell PTR specialization'da geldi.
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
burada amaç,
sadece bu işlemlerin,
atomik olarak yapıldığını,
bir örnek üstünde,
göstermek.
Mesela bakın,
atomik PTR'ye,
dizinin,
ilk elemanının,
adresiyle,
ilk değer verdim.
Sonra,
Pointer'ı 1 arttırdım.
Bu işlem,
Atomic Operation,
her ne kadar,
burada bir önemi olmasa da,
sonra,
load fonksiyonunu çağırarak,
değerinin,
ar artı 1,
yani dizinin,
pointer aritmetine göre,
bir ingilizce elemanı olduğunu,
assert ettim.
Burada kullandım,
C'den bildiğiniz,
assert makrosu.
Yani,
bu assert'ın fail olursa,
stud abort çağırılacak,
siz de göreceksiniz.
Sonra,
artı eşitle,
PTR'nin değerini,
bir arttırdım.
Yine,
ar artı 2 olacak.
Eksi eksi dedim.
Arkadaşlar,
ar artı,
1 olacak.
Hatta şunu diyebilir miyim?
Bir de onu da göstereyim.
PTR'nin,
arkadaşlar,
patch add fonksiyonu,
ve burada da,
şu anda,
ar artı 1'di,
3 toplarsam,
o zaman,
ar artı 4 olması lazım.
Değil mi?
Bu assert'ın,
fail olmaması gerekir.
O,
sana ise,
user defined type içinde,
pointer kullanımı,
save oluyor.
Kesinlikle.
Pointer'ın,
neyi point ettiğinden,
bağımsız.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Pointer,
hangi türden,
nesneyi gösterirse,
göstersin.
Burada,
atomik olan,
pointer.
Dolayısıyla,
pointer'ın,
pointinin,
türünün,
ne olduğunun,
doğrudan,
bir önemi,
yok.
Evet.
Peki,
devam.
arkadaşlar,
bakın,
yine,
burada,
temaların,
çok büyük çoğunluğunda,
biz,
hep,
data race,
olmaması,
üstünde durduk.
Yani,
işlemin,
atomik olması,
data race'i,
engeliyor.
Bu arada,
C++'da,
kullanmasak da,
biraz tuhaf bir şekilde,
C ile,
tabi C'nin daha sonraki standartlarıyla,
bir uyum sağlasın diye,
arkadaşlar,
bazı,
global fonksiyonlar da var.
İşte buradaki,
örneğin,
arkadaşlar,
store ve load fonksiyonları yerine,
global fonksiyon olan,
atomik store'a,
atomik değişkenin adresi,
ve değeri veriyorum.
Yine,
atomik load fonksiyonlar da,
değişkenin adresini veriyorum.
Yani,
C ile uyum sağlamak için,
oluşturulmuş bu fonksiyonlar,
global fonksiyonlar,
ve isimleri,
işte burada görüyorum,
atomik underscore,
arkadaşlar,
hangi işlem yapılacaksa,
o işlem,
ve bunlar bizden,
atomik değişkenimizin,
adresini istiyor.
biraz da şundan bahsedeyim,
geçen derste konuşmuştuk.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi standart diyor ki,
lock free olması,
garanti altında olan,
sadece tek atomik tür,
atomik flag türü.
onun dışındaki,
atomik türlerin,
herhangi biri için,
tam sayı türleri dahil,
user defined türler dahil,
işlemin,
atomisitinin,
mutex kullanılarak mı yapıldığı,
yoksa mutex kullanmadan,
doğrudan,
instruction'ın atomik olması nedeniyle mi,
yapıldığını,
test etmek için de,
sınıfın,
a,
is lock free fonksiyonu var.
Bu,
runtime'da çalışıyor.
Burası bir karmaşık mevzu ama,
arkadaşlar,
bazen,
compile time'da,
atomik değişkenin,
lock free olup olmadığı,
compile time'da değil de,
runtime'da saptanabiliyor.
belirli parametrelerle ilgili,
sistemdeki.
Bu yüzden,
kısaca şöyle söyleyelim.
Eğer siz,
runtime'da sınanmasını istiyorsanız,
örneğin bir atomik değişkeniniz var.
Atomic,
int,
x,
if,
is lock free.
Bu fonksiyonu çağırıyorsunuz.
Yani,
eğer runtime'da,
herhangi bir şekilde,
bunun,
işlemin,
bir mutex altında yapılıp yapılmayacağı,
bilgisini get etmek için.
Eğer böyle bir değişme ihtimali varsa.
Ama compile time'da kontrol etmek için,
doğrudan,
arkadaşlar,
sınıfın,
constexpr,
statik veri elemanı var.
Yani,
atomic,
intin,
atomic int bu tür,
statik veri elemanına,
ulaşmak için,
çözünürlük operatörünü kullanıyorum.
Is always lock free.
Bu,
boolean bir,
statik veri elemanı,
constexpr,
arkadaşlar,
ve bunun değeri,
true ise,
lock free her zaman,
değil ise,
lock free değil.
Yani,
mutex kullanılıyor olabilir.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
atomik işlemlerle ilgili,
çok böyle,
mülakatlarda da sorulan,
klasik bir soru var.
Ben de o soruyu size soracağım.
Şimdi,
bir atomik değişkenim var.
Atomic,
int,
x0.
Takip edin.
Burada,
bir fonksiyon var,
bank,
bank fonksiyonun içinde,
bir döngü var.
Diyelim ki,
arkadaşlar,
10.000 kez dönüyor.
Döngünün içine,
ayrı ayrı,
kodlar yazacağım.
Şimdilik burayı kapatıyorum.
Ve,
şöyle bir main fonksiyonu yazalım.
Main,
vektör başlık dosyasını,
yine dahil edelim.
Bir,
c-thread vektörü,
oluşturalım.
Arkadaşlar,
stut vektörün,
stut c-thread açılımı,
thread başlık dosyası,
ne diyelim,
thread vektörü,
t-vek,
diyelim ki,
20 kere dönen bir döngü,
döngünün her turunda,
and place back,
ve,
word load olarak da,
who'yu,
geçiyorum,
full mu,
harf neymiştik,
pank'a geçiyorum.
Süper.
Şimdi,
bu döngü çalıştıktan sonra,
ve,
bu nested scope'un sonunda,
bu da ne demek,
threadler join ettikten sonra,
buna dikkat,
özellikle bu amaçla,
nested scope'u kullanıyorum ki,
artık bütün threadlerin,
burada join ettiği,
garantisi var.
ve,
atomik değişkenimize ne ismi vermiştik,
x,
x'in,
değerini yazdırıyorum.
Şimdi,
soru,
arkadaşlar,
artı artı,
x,
10.000 çarpı,
10,
100.000,
değil mi?
20 thread olduğuna göre,
200.000 mi olması gerekiyor.
Evet,
10.000 kez arttırdığına göre,
20 x 10.000,
ben de aritmetik biraz dayıp.
Evet,
burada,
herhangi bir şekilde,
200.000 olmama ihtimali var mı?
Bir data race var mı?
Cevap,
neden var Kaan Can?
Değişkeni mi atomik?
Anladınız değil mi?
Atomik olduğu için,
böyle bir risk yok.
Bu birinci soru.
Şüphesiz bu değişken,
atomik olmasaydı,
onu göstermeme gerek var mı bilmiyorum.
Arkadaşlar,
böyle bir garanti veremezdim.
Yani,
şöyle olsaydı,
bu artık,
hepimiz biliyoruz,
defalarca konuştuk.
Evet,
A necat yine,
200.000 çıktı demeyin,
o tamamen,
çıkmaya da bilir.
Yani,
onu biliyoruz ki,
daha önceki örneklerde,
gördük.
Mesela,
biraz arttırdığım zaman,
o bozabilir.
Ya da bazen,
bakın,
tamamen değişti,
görüyorsunuz değil mi?
Peki,
şimdi devam.
Zaten bunu 100.000 yapalım.
Bunu yine,
atomik yapalım.
Tut,
atomik,
int.
Evet,
şimdi ikinci soru.
Önce basit sorular.
X artı artı deseydim,
herhangi bir şekilde,
data race olmayacağı garantisi var mı yine?
Cevap,
var.
çünkü bu işlem de atomik.
Yani,
bunu işlerleyip çalıştırmıyorum,
bu basit.
Bunun cevabını da bugün verdim ama,
belki,
onu konuşmadan sorsaydım,
burada,
data race olabilir mi diye,
cevap ne?
Evet.
Çünkü,
X artı bir işlemi,
atomik değil.
bakın,
bakın şimdi.
O değer olmadı.
İki ayrı operasyon var,
bravo.
Peki,
X eşit,
arkadaşlar,
böyle değil de,
X artı eşit bir yazsaydım,
cevap,
bu yine atomik olacaktı.
çünkü artı eşit,
atomik işlem yine.
Görüyoruz değil mi?
Devam.
Burada,
Hatch Ed'i çağırsaydım,
argüman olarak da bir geçseydim,
yine,
bunu da söylemeye gerek yok,
değer,
yine,
iki milyon olma garantisini taşıyordu.
Peki,
şimdi bakın,
ayrı soru.
X change fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum.
X exchange,
X artı bir.
Evet,
işlem atomik mi?
X'in storu,
X artı bir ile,
evet,
cevap hayır,
atomik değil.
Atomik değil,
çünkü,
bakın,
X yine,
arkadaşlar,
nasıl bir değişken,
atomik değişken.
O zaman,
bu işlem atomik değil ki,
arayan anlaşıldı mı?
Genelde burada,
nedense,
evet,
data race yok cevabı geliyor,
ama burada data race var.
yine araya o toplama işlemi girdiği için.
Gördük değil mi?
Evet,
peki,
biraz daha tuhaf hale getirelim.
Int expected,
eşittir,
x,
while,
arkadaşlar,
x'in,
compare exchange,
strong'u,
expected,
ve x artı bir.
Takip edin.
Burada da,
döngünün gövdesi,
null statement.
Evet,
hadi bakalım,
burada data race var mı,
yok mu?
Cevap,
yok.
Data race yok.
Çünkü zaten,
compare exchange,
strong.
Arkadaşlar,
bu amaçla yapılan bir işlem değil mi?
Bir daha soruyorum,
var mı,
yok mu?
Evet.
Peki.
Neden var?
Yine x artı bir.
Ama,
şöyle yazsaydım,
arkadaşlar,
izleyin,
x,
ne diyelim,
değişkenimizin ismi neydi?
x load,
bakın,
bu da,
int,
while,
buraya da,
while artı bir koysaydım,
şimdi,
cevabınızı verin yine,
olur muydu?
Yani,
2 milyon olur muydu?
Data race var mı?
Cevap,
evet,
yine,
data race var.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Peki,
soru,
burada,
compare exchange,
strong'u kullanarak,
bunu,
şuraya,
kod yazarak,
x değişkeninin değerini,
hadi bu da soru açık kalsın size,
garantili olarak,
data race olmadan,
bir arttırmak için,
nasıl bir,
kod yazabilirdim?
Evet,
bu da,
sorumuz.
Bir düşünün bakalım.
Siz düşünürken,
ben de,
şimdi,
yavaş yavaş,
arkadaşlar,
konuyu,
değiştireyim ve,
şu,
memory order,
konusuna,
gelelim.
Arkadaşlar,
önce,
memory order ne demek?
Biraz bundan bahsetmemiz gerekiyor.
Yani,
memory order demekle,
kast edilen ne?
Memory order demekle,
kast edilen,
birden fazla thread,
çalıştığı zaman,
bir thread'in,
örneğin,
bellek üstünde,
yaptığı işlemlerin,
sonuçlarının,
başka bir thread tarafından,
görülme garantisi var mı,
yok mu?
Yani,
işlemlerde böyle bir sıralama,
söz konusu mu,
değil mi?
Yani,
threadler,
değişkenlerin değerlerini,
hangi sırayla görecek,
böyle bir garanti var mı,
yok mu?
Bu konuya,
genel olarak,
memory order deniyor.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
az önce gösterdiğim,
fonksiyonların,
aslında,
hepsinin,
bir memory order nesi var,
parametresi var.
Şimdi,
bu memory order parametreleri,
bunlardan biri olacak,
ama biri deprecate edildi.
İzleyin,
evet,
arkadaşlar,
memory order relaxed,
memory order consume,
memory order acquire,
memory order release,
memory order acquire release,
memory order sequential consistent.
Arkadaşlar,
dikkat ederseniz,
buradaki memory order,
bir inum dürü.
Dolayısıyla,
bu az önce söylediğim,
arada,
underscore olan isimler,
bunlar,
aslında ne?
Sabitler,
numaralandırma sabitleri.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Bunların her biri,
aslında bir,
enumeration constant.
Ama şimdi,
bir şeye dikkat etmenizi istiyorum.
Bu türün,
type def ismi neymiş?
Memory order,
değil mi?
Yani,
türün ismi memory order.
Az önceki fonksiyonlardan,
herhangi birine bakın.
İzleyin.
Mesela,
atomic,
int,
arkadaşlar,
x,
x'in örneği,
store fonksiyonunu çağırayın.
x'in store fonksiyonunun,
gördüğünüz gibi,
ikinci parametresinin,
memory order türünden olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Yani diyor ki,
sen buraya,
az önceki sabitlerden,
birini geçeceksin.
Arkadaşlar,
işte bu,
sabitlerden hangisinin,
geçildiği,
benlik üstünde yapılan,
işlemin,
hangi garantilere,
verdiğine,
karşılık geliyor.
Burada tekrar söylüyorum,
şu memory order,
konsum,
2020 ile eklendi,
sonra pek de mantıklı olmadı,
ortaya çıkınca,
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam,
2023 ile,
deprecate edildi.
Şimdi tekrar buraya bir dönelim.
Önce,
memory order,
relax'den,
başlayalım.
Arkadaşlar,
en gevşek,
memory order,
relax'd.
Sadece ve sadece,
işlemin,
atomik olma garantisini veriyor.
Herhangi bir şekilde,
bir threadte yapılan,
işlemlerin sonucunun,
aynı atomik değişken,
üstünde,
ondan bahsediyorum.
bir başka threadte,
görülür olması garantisi yok.
Yani bu ne demek?
Memory order,
relax'di,
ne ile kullanamazsınız?
Senkronizasyon amaçlı,
kullanamazsınız.
Demiştik ya,
atomik değişkenlerin,
bizi ilgilendiren,
iki tane önemli özelliği var.
Bir,
atomik işlemlerin,
bölünemez olması,
yani data res olmaması.
Ama iki,
ordering sağlaması.
Ama tabii,
ordering sağlaması derken,
işte onu sağlayacak mı,
sağlamayacak mı,
fonksiyona geçtiğimiz argümanın,
bu memory order kategorilerinden,
hangisi olduğu ile ilgili.
Arkadaşlar,
diğer taraftan,
bu da herhalde,
bir,
ne diyelim,
sürpriz olmayacak.
Ne kadar çok garanti verirse,
maliyet o kadar fazla.
Buraya dikkat.
yani bu çok genel bir ilke programlamada,
özellikle multi-track programlamada.
Bendek üstünde yapılan işlemlerde,
ne kadar fazla garanti verilirse,
maliyet o kadar,
o denli fazla.
mesela,
ben hem,
birazdan bahsedeceğimiz,
bir ordering garantisi,
ver,
istiyorum.
Ama,
yine,
bununla beraber,
bir visibility garantisi de,
elde etmek istiyorum,
diyorsanız,
en pahalısı bu.
Ama,
en ucusu da,
relaxed memory order.
Memory order,
relaxed olunca,
şu anlama geliyor,
işlemin,
bölünemez olmasının dışında,
hiçbir garanti yok.
Ama olabilecek,
en düşük maliyette bu.
Arkadaşlar,
bu son derece önemli.
Neden?
Çünkü,
çok sık yapılan bir hata.
Fakat siz böyle bir atomik değişkende,
gidip de store fonksiyonunu,
bu şekilde,
ya da store ne diyelim,
patch,
add fonksiyonunu,
bu şekilde çağırırsanız,
aslında burada,
memory order değeri,
olabilecek en yüksek garanti seviyesi.
Yani,
buradaki,
şu sabiti geçmiş oluyorsunuz fonksiyonlar.
neredeydi?
Şuradaydı değil mi?
Evet.
Bu sabiti geçmiş oluyorsunuz.
Memory order,
sequential consistent.
Oysa,
eğer burada,
bir,
sıralama talebi yoksa,
örneğin bunu bir sayıç olarak kullanacaksanız,
en tipi görmeyiz.
Atomik değişken,
üstünde yapılan,
işlemden,
önceki işlemlerin,
bu değişkenin değerinin,
get edilmesinden sonra,
görülebilir olması,
gibi bir,
arkadaşlar,
default her zaman en pahalı olan,
Alihan Bostra,
evet,
default her zaman en pahalı olan,
en pahalı olan da,
arkadaşlar,
bu arada,
buradaki terimler,
C++'ın terimleri değil,
bunlar genel programlama terimleri,
bakın,
bir,
sequential consistency,
yani Java'da da,
o diye alsanız,
mesela Java'da direkt model bu,
yani Java'da multi-track programlamada,
zaten sequential consistency hazır geliyor,
bütün işlemler,
sequential consistency,
bu,
arkadaşlar,
ikinci terim,
acquire,
tıpkı bu kelimeyi yazmakta zorlanmışımdır,
release semantik,
deflar söylüyorum,
bunlar C++ terim mi,
ne alaka,
bunlar genel programlama terimi,
aslında bizi ilgilendiren,
bu ikisi,
sequential consistency mi olacak,
acquire release semantik mi olacak,
yoksa,
relaxed,
semantik mi,
şimdi biz,
relaxed semantik'i konuşuyoruz,
relaxed semantik demek,
sadece bölünemezlik garantisi veriliyor demek,
yani sıralama ilişkin hiçbir garanti yok,
visibility'ye ilişkin hiçbir garanti yok,
bu da ne demek,
mesela,
sizin,
bir atomik sayıcınız var,
bugün yazdığımız kodlardan,
herhangi birini almanız,
arkadaşlar,
sizin bir atomik sayıcınız var,
nasıl o koda geri dönsek daha iyi olacak ama,
neyse yazayım,
ve diyelim ki,
farklı threadler,
bunu arttırıyor,
azaltıyor,
yani art artı count yapıyor,
eksi eksi count yapıyor,
ama,
sizin için önemli olan,
arkadaşlar,
bu işlemin,
data release'e,
sebep olmaması,
yani sonuçta herhangi bir thread,
bin kere arttıracaksa,
yine bin kere arttıracak,
araya başka bir işlemin girmesini istemiyorsunuz,
ama hangi thread'in daha önce,
bu değişkeni değiştirdi,
sonra o,
bir takım değişkenlerin,
değerin başka bir thread,
bu garantiyle okudu falan,
böyle bir şey yok,
anlaşıldı değil mi,
bu da şu demek,
mesela böyle durumda,
programcılar yine gidiyor,
arkadaşlar,
relax semantiyi kullanmak yerine,
efendim,
daha maliyetli bir semantiyi,
örneğin,
akaryoliniz semantini,
ya da,
efendim,
sequential consistency kullanıyor,
biraz bu arada,
tabii şöyle bir şey de var,
şunu da söyleyelim,
arkadaşlar,
belirli işlemcilerde,
belirli işlemlerin,
hani sıra dışı şekilde,
ilave verdiği garantiler de var,
onu işlemcinin kendi dokumentasyonuna bakacaksınız,
mesela bir işlemcide şöyle bir şey olabilir mi,
intürü üstünde yapılan bütün işlemler,
sanki atomik bir türmüş gibi bölünemez,
bu olabilir,
ama genel olarak böyle bir garanti yok,
anlaşıldı değil mi,
peki,
biz şimdi buraya geri dönelim,
ve gerçekten,
biraz hızlı bir şekilde,
arkadaşlar,
relaxed semantiyi kullanarak,
counter değişkenimizin değerini arttıralım,
ya da eksiltelim,
mesela full fonksiyonu,
yine,
yüz bin kez dönen bir döngüde,
altın değerini,
patch add fonksiyonuna çağrı yaparak,
ama bakalım,
memory order parametresi olarak,
slot,
memory order,
relaxed bunu kullandı,
ve,
bir diğerini geçti,
ters yazdık,
bir,
stood,
memory order,
relaxed,
şimdi oldu,
bar fonksiyonu,
bu da patch subtract,
ama bu da arkadaşlar,
relax,
ve ben yine,
tane vektör olayım,
vektörün,
c-thread açılımı,
vek,
20 kez dönen bir döngü içinde,
if,
i,
mod 2,
bu durumda,
which,
and place back,
c-thread,
bu,
arkadaşlar,
ve,
buraya geldiğinde programın akışı,
fredler join edilmiş olacağı için,
ben,
değişkenimin ismi neydi,
c-net,
değerini yazdırayım,
işte bu,
en gevşek garanti,
yine,
burada bölünemezlik sağladığı için,
burada ben,
en düşük maliyetle,
arkadaşlar,
gördünüz,
ne yaptım,
otomik,
bu işlemleri,
gerçekleştirdim,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
izleyin,
gelelim ikinci garantiye,
bu arada çok güzel bir kod daha var,
yazdığım,
konuyu çok güzel anlatıyor bence,
bakın,
bu kod aslında gerçekten,
konuyu çok güzel anlatan bir kod,
hangi garanti verilmiyor,
arkadaşlar,
burada,
long-long türünden bir değişken var,
atomik,
long-long da olabilirdi,
int de olabilirdi,
orası çok da önemli değil,
ismi de data,
blue work fonksiyonu,
bu,
parametreye thread'in id'si yenecek,
yani benim verdiğim id,
önce id'yi yazdıracak,
arkadaşlar,
sonra,
patch add fonksiyonunun,
geri dönüş değerini yazdıracak,
patch add,
biliyorsunuz,
atomik değişkenin değerini,
bu kadar miktar arttırıyor,
bu da,
memory order parametresi,
ve geri dönüş değeri de,
bu işlemden önceki değer,
ve bu işlem,
arkadaşlar,
atomik,
şimdi,
8 tane thread oluşturdum,
hatta,
daha da fazla yapabilirdim,
neyse böyle kalsın,
ve ekran çıktısını görmenizi istiyorum,
arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
thread id,
6,
thread id'de,
6'da,
görülen,
değer 5,
bunun ne olduğunu anladınız mı,
yani,
değeri aslında,
6 yapmış,
fakat,
bu,
fetch add fonksiyonunda,
geri dönüş değeri,
5,
alttakine bakın,
4,
1,
arkadaşlar,
biz bunu bu sırayla görüyoruz,
ama sonuçta,
bir tanesi onu 0 yaptı,
biri 1 yaptı,
diğeri 2 yaptı,
3 yaptı,
4 yaptı,
5 yaptı,
6 yaptı,
ve 7 yaptı,
burada bir sıralama söz konusu değil,
ama işlemin,
atomik olması garantisi var,
gelelim,
acquire release semantini,
şimdi burası,
biraz zor anlaşılan kısım,
arkadaşlar,
acquire release semantiyi,
şunu sağlıyor,
bizim bir atomik değişkenimiz var,
atomik,
x,
atomik x değişkeni üstünde,
bir store işlemi yapılıyor,
store işlemi ne demek,
değişkenin değerini değiştiren bir işlem,
yani,
illa store fonksiyonu olması gerekmiyor,
arkadaşlar,
eşittir olabilir,
store olabilir,
efendim,
fetch add olabilir,
fetch sub olabilir,
önemli olan,
bir store işlemi olması,
diyelim ki,
fetch add,
bu atomik bir işlem değil mi,
ya da store,
embosik örnek,
bu,
atomik x'in,
başlangıçtaki değeri de,
efendim,
dört olsun,
eğer,
şimdi buraya çok dikkatli izleyin,
atomik değişkenin üstünde yapılan store işlemi,
memory order,
bellek sıralaması,
diye Türkçe'ye çeviriyorlar,
bellek sıralama düzeni olarak,
memory order acquire ise,
biz de yapalım o zaman,
memory order,
acquire,
yani deminki sabitlerden,
akaryo olan,
takip etmeye çalışan,
tamam,
şimdi,
çok dikkatli izleyin,
şu garanti var,
diyelim ki,
bu thread'te yapılan bir takım işlemler var,
bu değişkenlerin,
atomik olması da gerekmiyor,
mesela,
A değişkenine,
10 değeri atandı,
B değişkenine,
bunların türü,
beni ilgilendirmiyor,
Necati Ergin değeri atandı,
C değişkenine,
3.467 değeri atandı,
arkadaşlar,
takip edebiliyor musunuz,
evet,
şimdi,
izleyin,
eğer,
aynı atomik değişken,
üstünde,
bu sefer,
bir okuma işlemi,
mesela load,
tipik bir okuma işlemi,
onun da,
arkadaşlar,
özür dilerim,
burada acquire,
benim release diyecektim,
acquire olur mu,
release,
benim acquire release diye okuduğum için,
buraya yanlış yazdım,
önemli değil,
evet,
şimdi,
eğer,
store işlemi,
acquire,
memory order release ile yapılıyorsa,
aynı atomik değişkeni,
okuyan thread de,
oradaki okuma işlemi ne,
buraya dikkat,
arkadaşlar,
memory order,
acquire ile yapıyorsa,
mesela,
burada,
başka bir thread,
orada da şöyle bir kod var,
atomik eksin,
bakın,
aynı atomik değişkeni olacak,
atomik eksin,
load'u,
memory order,
acquire,
arkadaşlar,
zaten bakın,
release,
publish demek,
bazen ben de demin,
ismi yanlış yazdım,
nasıl anlattığım için,
değil mi,
yani serbest bırakmak,
anlamında,
acquire'da edinmek,
çok dikkat bilinize,
bu durumda,
şöyle bir senkronizasyon garantisi,
elde ediyorsunuz,
buradaki,
atomik değişkeni,
üstünde yapılan,
ama,
memory order,
acquire,
bellek düzeniyle,
okuma işleminden sonra,
buradaki store işleminden,
önceki,
bütün yazma işlemleri,
artık,
visible olacak,
yani,
artık,
hangi koşulla,
kod üretilmek zorunda,
arkadaşlar,
buradaki işlemler,
buraya,
geçemez,
burayı anladık mı,
yani,
buradaki işlemler,
bu load'dan sonrasına,
geçemez,
dolayısıyla,
neden emin olarak,
bu kodu yazabiliriz,
artık load'dan sonra,
store'dan önceki,
işlemlerin,
sonucunun,
buradaki load'dan sonra,
görülme garantisine,
güvenerek,
kod yazabiliriz,
işte bakın,
producer,
consumer,
modeli,
zaten tamamen,
bu demek,
gerçekten bunu deneyelim mi,
bir kod yazalım beraber,
birazdan ara vereceğim,
gerçekten,
acquire release semantiyi,
tutuyor mu,
arkadaşlar,
şimdiye kadar,
bir senkronizasyonu,
yani,
bu happens before,
ilişkisini,
senkronize with ilişkisini,
geçen derste,
tek tek saydım,
hangi durumlarda var,
arkadaşlar,
onu,
hayır load satırı dahil değil,
load'dan sonra,
onu tek tek söylemiştim,
ama bakın şimdi,
başka bir,
synchronized with durumu,
daha oluşuyor,
izleyin,
word for,
burada değişkenler var,
bakın bunlar,
otomik olmak zorunda da değil,
index eşittir,
0,
suit string,
str,
arkadaşlar,
eşittir,
necati,
efendim,
ne olsun,
yeter mi,
bir tane daha mı koyalım,
tamam,
int,
ye,
eşittir,
0,
şimdi,
fu'ya bakın,
önce bu değişkenlerin,
değerini değiştirecek,
x eşit,
9,99,
str eşit,
Alihan,
ye eşit,
3333,
ve sonra,
buraya dikkat,
benim bir atomik değişkenim var,
suit,
atomik,
arkadaşlar,
ne,
bool,
flag,
eşittir,
false,
ve şimdi,
atomik değişkeninin değerini,
true'ya çekiyor,
flag eşittir,
true,
ama bunu,
bu şekilde değil de,
nasıl yapıyor,
memori order release,
kullanmak için,
x nokta,
x miydi,
flag,
flag nokta,
arkadaşlar,
store,
ve,
boolean value,
izleyin,
true,
ve,
stut,
memori order,
release ediyorum,
şimdi,
bu ne demek,
bir başka,
thread de,
aynı atomik değişkenden,
değeri okuduğumuzda,
arkadaşlar,
değerin,
değeri okuduğumuzda,
değeri okuduktan sonra,
buradaki işlemlerin,
görülür olma garantisini,
elde ediyoruz,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
yani,
bu şu demek,
ben,
diğer thread de,
buradaki flag değişkenini,
true olarak,
okuduğum noktada,
aslında,
ne garantim var,
buradaki işlemlerin,
görülme garantisi var,
ve arkadaşlar,
buraya dikkat,
buradaki işlemler,
sıralama olarak,
derleyici,
mesela,
şöyle bir optimizasyon yapabilir mi,
kritik yer burası,
ordering ile ilgili,
ee,
normalde,
hani,
derleyici,
kodun daha hızlı çalıştığını düşünerek,
observable behavior,
değişmiyor diye,
işlemlerin sırasını değiştirebilir,
değil mi,
ama şimdi,
örneğin,
buradaki işlemleri,
buraya alabilir mi,
cevap hayır,
artık bu,
yasaklanmış durumda,
çünkü,
buradaki store işlemi,
bu garantiyi veriyor,
şimdi,
diğer thread'e yazacağız,
arkadaşlar,
mesela,
diğer thread'de de,
şöyle bir kod olsun,
void bar,
bu da aslında,
consumer'a karşılık geliyor,
değil mi,
void bar,
buraya dikkat şimdi,
load edecek,
arkadaşlar,
neydi değişkenin ismi,
bir var döngüsü içinde,
while,
flag'in,
load'u,
ama,
bellek düzeni olarak ne kullanacak,
memory order,
acquire kullanacak,
stud,
memory order,
acquire,
arkadaşlar,
evet,
false döndüğü sürece,
bu döngü dönsün,
şimdi artık,
programın akışı,
load'tan sonraki,
koda geldiğinde,
yani artık burası,
bizim flag'imizi,
true olarak gördüğünde,
arkadaşlar,
şu işlemlerin,
yapılma garantisi var,
şimdi bana şöyle diyebilirsiniz,
belki şöyle olduğunu,
zannediyordunuz,
ediyordunuz,
Necati zaten böyle diyeyim,
değil işte,
yani bu garantinin,
mesela,
relax modeli olsaydı,
burada,
bunlar memory order,
relaxed olsaydı,
ben,
buradaki kodda,
artık bu değişkenlerin,
değerinin değiştirildiği,
garantisine,
onu da göstereceğim,
güvenebilir miydim,
cevap,
hayır,
güvenemezdim,
hatta bakın şimdi,
bunu göstermek için,
şöyle bir kod yazayım,
biraz arayı geciktirdim,
assert başlık dosyasını da aynı edeyim,
ve,
buraya assertion'lar koyayım,
assert,
arkadaşlar,
neydi,
x eşittir,
9,
99,
assert,
y eşittir,
3.333,
assert,
str eşittir,
Alihan,
bakın şimdi,
bir derleyim buraya kadar,
evet,
şimdi izleyin,
main fonksiyonu içinde,
bin kez dönen bir döngüde,
önce döngüye girmeden,
şu değerleri yükleyeyim,
hatta bunlar,
default construct edilmiş de olabilir,
problem değil,
mesela bakın,
x eşittir,
sıfır,
arkadaşlar,
y eşittir,
sıfır,
str eşittir,
null string,
şimdi,
iki thread oluşturayım,
c thread,
jt,
ya da t1,
bununla,
uyu çalıştırayım,
barı çalıştırayım,
arkadaşlar,
eğer benim söylediğim garanti,
olmasaydı,
e-code'da ben yanlışlık yapmamışsam,
izleyin,
buradaki,
assert,
yeni değer görüyorsunuz,
yani şurada yüklenen değer,
buradaki assert,
assert'unlar,
fail olabilirdi değil mi,
çünkü yeteri kadar da deniyorum,
yani o görünürlük garantisi,
bir kere olsa tesadüf dersiniz,
iki kere olsa tesadüf dersiniz,
ama bin kerede de,
bunun tesadüf olma ihtimali yok,
değil mi,
önce sentax hatasını düzeltelim,
t2,
evet,
bir yerde bir hata yaptık,
oraya bakalım şimdi,
evet,
flag,
load,
x eşittir,
9,
99,
str,
hem de ara vermiş oluruz,
str eşittir,
Alihan,
y eşittir,
3333,
flag'i,
true,
false yapmamışız,
anlaşıldı değil mi,
flag,
eşittir,
false,
tamam,
hatayı çabuk bulduk,
başka bir hata yoksa,
şunu da kapatalım,
evet,
demeyelim şimdi,
gördünüz mü,
assertion,
bir kere bile fail olmadı,
ama şimdi bakın,
izleyin,
ben burada,
memory order,
acquire yerine,
relaxed'i kullansaydım,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
yine burada,
memory order,
relax'i kullansaydım,
relax,
demin yanlışlıkla atmışım,
evet,
memory order,
acquire relax değil,
sadece relax,
evet,
sabitler birbirine karışmaz,
şimdi böyle bir garanti var mı,
belki böyle bir garanti olduğunu,
düşünüyor olabilirsiniz,
genelde de,
özellikle böyle,
Java,
C-Shark gibi dillerden gelenler,
bu garantinin sürekli olduğunu,
düşünüyorlar,
ama hayır,
burada böyle bir garanti yok,
yani şimdi,
assertion fail olabilir mi,
cevap evet,
yani şu anda,
memory order,
relax olması,
artık burada bir,
ne garantisi vermiyor,
görünürlük garantisi vermiyor,
bir ara verelim,
aradan sonra,
tekrar devam edeceğiz,
21.35'de devam ediyoruz,
arkadaşlar,
şimdi şu koda bakın,
dikkat,
üç tane atomik,
buğul değişken var,
yani,
atomik ve atomik,
templatinin,
bul açılımı,
üçünün de değeri,
false,
bir de string değişkeni var,
az önce kodun benzeri,
ama şimdi konuyu,
biraz daha iyi gösteriyor,
arkadaşlar,
full fonksiyonu,
çağırdığı zaman,
name string değişkenine,
necati yazısını atıyor,
ve ondan sonra,
flag 1'i,
store işlemiyle,
true değere getiriyor,
ama memory order release ile,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
arkadaşlar,
bar fonksiyonu ise,
önce döngüsel bir yapı içinde,
az önceki,
benim yazdığım kodda olduğu gibi,
sürekli,
flag 1'in değerini,
load ediyor,
false olduğu sürece dönüyor,
ve artık programın akışı,
buraya geldiğinde,
buraya dikkat,
programın akışı,
buraya geldiğinde,
neden eminiz,
diğer thread'in,
aynı otomik değişkeni üstünde,
yani flag 1 üstünde,
set işlemi yapan,
thread'in,
o store işleminden,
önceki operasyonu,
artık burada görülür olmak zorunda,
bakın,
zamansal olarak,
işlemin daha önce yapılması başka,
visible olması,
başka,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
evet,
bu durumda,
burada,
bar fonksiyonu içinde,
name artı eşittir,
ergin yazısı,
yazıyı,
necati ergin yapacak,
fakat,
bu da bir,
atomik değişkeni üstünde,
store yapıyor,
ama bakın,
buradaki atomik değişken başka,
flag 2,
takip edebiliyor muyuz,
evet,
ve flag 2 üstünde,
bu sefer,
store işlemi yaptı,
onu da,
arkadaşlar,
release'e yaptı,
bu arada,
barda önce,
load işlemi yapıldığını,
tekrar gösterelim,
ve,
sonra ergin,
sonra tekrar store,
fakat,
bas fonksiyonu da,
flag 2'nin değeri,
load'da yine,
memory order,
ekayer kullandığına dikkat edin,
flag 2'nin değeri,
false olduğu sürece,
dönecek,
ama,
aynı atomik değişkeni,
üstünde işlem yapıldığı için,
bir senkronizasyon ilişkisi olduğu için,
artık bu store'dan önceki,
bu kodun da,
sonucunun,
yani bellek üstünde yapılan değişikliğin,
artık visible olma garantisi var,
yani bu ne demek,
ben,
fuyu,
barı,
bazı,
3 ayrı thread'te çalıştırsam,
sonra,
bu threadleri,
join etsem,
programın akışı,
test fonksiyonunun sonuna geldiğimde,
name'in,
Necati Ergincan olması gerekiyor,
arkadaşlar,
bir şeye dikkat edin,
testte,
her defa bunu,
bir döngü içinde,
test fonksiyonunu,
çalıştıracağım,
ve her defasında,
şu flag'leri,
false değeri çektim,
ve name'i de,
null string yaptım,
şimdi takip edin,
100 bin kere,
testi çağırıyorum,
eğer bu garanti olmasaydı,
burada,
Akire Relief Semantik'i kullanılmasaydı,
bu döngüden çıktıktan sonra,
şu işlemin,
görülür olma garantisi yoktu,
çünkü,
herhangi bir şekilde,
ne yapabilir,
bunu sıralayabilir,
tamamen derleyicinin,
ürettiği koda bağlı,
yani derleyicinin yaptığı optimizasyondan,
ya da işlemci tarafında yapılabilecek,
optimizasyonlardan,
etkilenecekti,
işte arkadaşlar,
bu da bir senkronizasyon,
şimdi,
synchronized bit ilişkisini hatırlayın,
hani,
thread'i çalıştıran kodla,
çalışan thread,
thread'i çalıştıran kod,
arkadaşlar,
thread çalışmadan önce,
benlik üstünde,
hangi işlemleri yaptıysa,
thread'in çalışmaya başlamasıyla,
o işlemler,
görülür durumda,
senkronizasyon ilişkisi bir,
hatırlıyor musunuz,
iki,
dedik,
arkadaşlar,
lock unlock,
lock ve unlock arasında,
bellek üstünde yapılan işlemler,
aynı mutex üstünde çalışan thread'lerde,
unlock'tan sonra,
o kritik bölgedeki,
değişikliklerin,
ya da kritik bölgede çalışan kodların,
sonuçlarının,
unlock'tan sonra,
arkadaşlar,
o kodda,
ne olur,
ne olması demek,
görülür olması demek,
başka neydi,
future promise de vardı,
böyle bir,
senkronizasyon ilişkisi,
evet,
hocam,
anlayamadığım bir yer var,
her release,
bir recovery ile eşleşmeli mi,
kesinlikle,
arkadaşlar,
sentax hatası olmasa bile,
o zaman bu garanti kayboluyor,
aynen dediğiniz gibi,
her release,
bir acquire ile,
eşlenmek zorunda,
evet,
hocam,
anlayamadığım bir yer var,
her release,
bir acquire ile eşleşmeli mi,
eğer durum böyleyse,
bir sorun daha var,
durum böyle,
aynı atomik değişkende,
iki defa release,
iki defa acquire,
kullanılabiliyor mu,
hayır,
arkadaşlar,
yani iki kere,
release,
iki kere acquire kullanılabiliyor mu,
derken,
şunu kastediyorsunuz,
eğer,
tabii ki kullanılabilir,
ama,
tekrar aynı değerine,
getirmek kaydıyla,
yani iki kere,
on kere kullanmanız,
soruyu doğru anladıysam,
hiçbir kötü etkisi yok,
evet,
hangi release,
hangi acquire ile eşlenecek,
belki ben soruyu anlamamış olabilirim,
Alian,
şimdi,
yani kapamda söylediğiniz senaryoyu,
kuramadım,
eğer bir kodla gösterirseniz,
beraber bakarız,
önemli olan,
atomik değişkenin,
aynı olması,
işte burada,
bu döngüden çıktığı anda,
evet,
bakın,
bu döngüden çıktığı anda,
ben,
flag 1'in değerinin,
true olduğunu biliyorum,
o problem değil,
o garanti zaten var,
ama problem şu,
true olduğunu biliyorum da,
buradaki işlemler,
burada,
sonuçları görünür durumda mı,
burayı anladık mı,
görünür durumda olması garantisi için,
işte bir tarafın,
release etmesi,
diğer tarafında,
atomik değişkenin değerini,
arkadaşlar,
okurken,
akı ayrı,
kullanması gerekiyor,
memori order olarak,
ama tabi,
hem okuma,
hem yazma işlemi ise,
o zaman,
zaten hatırlayın,
şurada bir sabit daha vardı,
o da,
bazı,
atomik işlemler,
hem okuma,
hem yazma işlemi yapıyor ya,
işte orada da,
şunu kullanıyorsunuz,
memori order,
akı ayrı,
release,
yani akı ayrı ile release,
birbiriyle ilişkili olarak,
kullanılmak zorunda mı,
kesinlikle evet,
store işlemini yapan,
onu publish etmek için,
store işlemini,
release ile yapacak,
diğer tarafta,
o değişikliklerden,
faydalanmak için,
load işlemini,
akı ayrı ile yapacak,
yani aslında bu,
eğer daha alt seviyeli,
programlama ile uğraştıysanız,
memori bariyer kullanılıyor,
arka planda tipik olarak,
peki,
şimdi devam edelim,
bu sanıyorum,
burası artık net olarak anlaşıldı,
böylece yeni bir,
senkronizasyon biçimi daha gördük,
atomik değişkenleri kullanarak,
gördüğünüz gibi atomik değişkenler,
sadece ne sağlamıyor,
sadece işlemlerin,
bölünemez olmasını sağlamıyor,
uygun bellek düzeni,
kategorisini kullanırsanız,
senkronizasyon ilişkisi de sağlıyor.
Hocam, çok thread olması durumunda,
bir akı ayrı yapıldıktan sonra,
tüm threadlerde visible oluyor mu?
Tüm threadlerde visible olması için,
yine aynı neyin kullanılması gerekiyor?
Arkadaşlar,
aynı atomik değişkenler,
load işleminin yapılması gerekiyor.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Yani siz aynı şekilde,
aynı döngüyü,
birden fazla threadde oluşturursanız,
yine herhangi bir şekilde,
bir problem yok.
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
burada bir örneği göstereceğim,
çok güzel,
yine bir arkadaşın sunumundan,
bakın şimdi,
memory order'ı,
çok güzel gösteren bir örnek.
şimdi,
bu tabii kolun tamamını göstermiyor ama,
bu kısmını anlamanız yeterli olacak.
Arkadaşlar,
bu için herhangi bir sınıf anlamında,
McUnique fonksiyonunu zaten biliyorsunuz,
McUnique fonksiyonu,
Unique PTR döndürüyor ama,
içeride,
dinamik ömürlü bir,
nesne oluşturuyor,
değil mi?
Niv ifadesiyle.
Ama bakın şimdi,
bu threadde,
Reddy'de,
bir değişken,
atomik değişken,
Reddy'nin,
store fonksiyonunu çağırıyor,
ve başlangıç değeri sıfır olan,
bir atomik değişkenin değerini,
bir yapıyor.
Ve ondan sonra,
yine burada store'da,
bellek,
sıralama düzeni olarak,
memory order release kullanıldığını görüyorsunuz.
Bu ne demek?
Bakın,
aslında çok önemli bir garanti.
Şimdi,
eğer ben buna karşılık gelen,
acquire işleminde yaparsam,
load işlemini,
memory order acquire ile yaparsam,
artık,
store'dan önceki,
bu işlemin sonucu,
görülür olacak.
Görülür olması ne demek?
Yani artık bu nesnenin,
hayata gelmemiş olması gibi bir ihtimal,
söz konusu olmayacak.
Burada da onu gösteriyor.
Şimdi bakın,
diğer threadde,
Reddy'nin load fonksiyonu,
load'un geri dönüş değeri,
sıfır olduğu sürece dönüyor.
arkadaşlar,
ama döngüden çıktıktan sonra,
artık,
acquire release,
release acquire,
aynı anlamda kullanıyorum,
semantik kullanıldığı için,
o store'dan önceki işlem,
gerçekleşmiş olmak zorunda.
eğer böyle bir garanti olmasaydı,
burada biz nesne hayata gelmeden,
o unique PTR,
unique PTR'dı değil mi?
Evet,
unique PTR nesnesiyle,
dangling pointer ile belki erişmiş olacaktık.
bu garantinin verilmesinin nedeni,
acquire release semantiği.
Arkadaşlar,
izleyin,
zaten bakın burada,
acquire memory published by other threads.
yani,
eğer acquire ile okuma yapıyorsam,
diğer thread'lerdeki,
aynı atomik değişkeni kullanan,
diğer thread'te,
arkadaşlar,
oradaki işlemler,
görülür.
Release de,
ne anlama geliyor?
biz,
adeta,
diğer tarafa,
şöyle bir sinyal vermiş oluyoruz.
Artık benim,
sen bunu okursan,
tabii,
acquire,
bellek düzeniyle,
benim yaptığım değişikliklerin sonucunu,
alırsın.
Arkadaşlar,
bu durumda dikkatli izleyin,
bir condition variable falan kullanmadım.
Doğrudan,
herhangi bir şekilde,
arkadaşlar,
condition variable kullanmadan,
ve bir kilit sistemi de kullanmadan,
görüyorsunuz,
kodlarda bir mutex falan,
da yok.
Ama,
yine de,
iki thread arasında,
koordinasyonu sağladık.
Şimdi gelelim,
nereye gelelim?
Şu,
sequential consistency'ye.
Arkadaşlar,
sequential consistency,
olabilecek en büyük garanti.
İşte bazı programlama dillerinde,
sequential consistency,
zaten default,
başka bir seçeneğe izin vermiyor.
Tabii,
sequest plus verim odaklı bir dili olduğu için,
diyor ki,
relaxed yetiyorsa,
relaxed'i kullan.
Senin istediğin sadece,
senkronizasyonsa,
o zaman,
acquire release semantini kullan.
Ama,
eğer,
aynı zamanda,
total order istiyorsan,
şimdi onun ne olduğunu anlatacağım,
o zaman,
sequential consistency,
olmak zorunda.
Arkadaşlar,
ne demek,
sequential consistency?
şimdi anlaşılması,
biraz başlangıçta,
zor olan kavramlardan biri de bu.
Şimdi çok dikkatli izleyin.
Sadece,
benim söylediklerime odaklanın.
Arkadaşlar,
iki tane thread var,
ve,
x'de,
y'de,
atomik değişkenler.
Thread 1'de,
x değişkeni üstünde bir store işlemi yapılıyor.
Ve,
ondan sonra,
yani,
o thread'teki fonksiyonun sırasıyla,
burada da bir load işlemi yapılıyor.
Takip edebiliyor musunuz?
Yani,
y'nin değeri,
load ediliyor.
Yani,
y'nin değeri okunuyor.
O da,
res bir değişkenine yazılıyor.
Önce,
burayı bir anlamaya çalışın.
Çünkü,
her şey burayla ilgili.
Thread 2'de ise,
arkadaşlar,
önce,
y store ediliyor.
Yani,
y'ye bir değeri yazılıyor.
Ondan sonra,
x'in değeri okunuyor.
Şimdi,
çok dikkatli izleyin.
Soru 1,
soru 1,
eğer,
burada,
bu işlemler,
sequential consistency,
bellek düzeniyle yapılıyorsa,
şu iki işlemin,
sırasında bir değişiklik olabilir mi?
Yani,
derleyici mesela,
bunu,
daha yukarı,
diğerini daha aşağıya alabilir mi?
Cevap,
hayır.
Derleyici,
böyle bir optimizasyon yapamaz.
Arkadaşlar,
ama tabii,
bakın,
sequential consistency'den bahsediyorum.
Aynı şekilde,
burada da,
bu iki işlem arasında,
atomik değişkenler üstünde yapılan işlemler arasında,
bir sırasal değişiklik yapamaz.
Ama şimdi,
çok dikkatli izleyin.
Peki,
bu threadler,
beraber koştuğunda,
bu işlemler,
bu işlemler hangi sırayla yapılacak?
Hangi sırayla yapılacak demekte,
kastettiğim şu,
sadece senkronizasyon değil.
Arkadaşlar,
yani threadler,
bu işlemleri,
aynı sırayla mı görecek?
Cevap,
evet.
İşte,
sequential consistency bunu sağlıyor.
Bu şu demek,
mesela,
şöyle olabilir mi?
Şöyle göstereyim.
Önce bu işlem,
sonra bu işlem,
sonra bu işlem olabilir mi?
Evet.
Önce bu,
sonra bu,
sonra bu olabilir mi?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
ya da şuna bakın.
Önce bu,
sonra bu,
sonra bu olabilir mi?
Evet.
yani buradaki bütün kombinasyonlar olabilir.
Sadece ne olamaz?
Bunların kendi içindeki yeri değişemez.
Arkadaşlar bakın,
yine bir arkadaşın slide'ından,
slide'ı ben hazırlamadım.
Ama gayet güzel gösteriyor.
İzleyin.
Diyor ki,
eğer bu thread'te,
ve bu thread'te bu işlemler varsa,
bunların sırası,
şu kombinasyonlardan biri olabilir.
Bakın burada time,
zaman ilerliyor.
X-Store,
bu yapıldı.
Y-Lot,
arkadaşlar bu yapıldı.
Y-Store,
bu yapıldı.
X-Lot,
Ama,
şimdi,
şuna bakın.
X-Store,
Y-Store,
bu yapıldı,
bu yapıldı.
Ondan sonra,
Y-Lot,
bu yapıldı,
bu yapıldı.
Gördüğünüz gibi,
bütün kombinasyonlar var.
Ya da mesela şuna bakalım.
Y-Store,
önce bu yapıldı.
X-Store,
sonra bu yapıldı.
Y-Lot,
X-Lot,
sonra bu yapıldı.
Buraya kadar tamam mı?
Tamam.
Ama şimdi,
sequential consistency,
ne garantisini veriyor?
Bu kombinasyonlardan,
herhangi biri olabilir.
olabilir.
Ama bütün threadler,
aynı sırayla bunları görecekler.
Yani,
örneğin,
eğer,
runtime'da sıra böyle gerçekleşmişse,
threadlerin,
hepsinde,
arkadaşlar,
aynı sıra söz konusu olacak.
Yani,
buna güvenerek,
kod yazabilirsiniz,
anlamı çıkıyor.
bakın,
Akire Release semantiğinde,
herhangi bir şekilde,
böyle bir garanti yok.
İşte,
buna total order,
yani,
bütün threadlerin,
aynı sırayı,
gözlemlemesi,
garantisi olması için,
bir total ordering olması için,
ne olması gerekiyor?
Sequential Consistency olması gerekiyor.
Bu arada,
yanlış anlaşılmasın,
sequential consistency,
neyi de kapsıyor tabii ki?
Akire Release'i de,
kapsıyor.
Çünkü,
bütün threadler,
o sırayla görmek zorunda.
Ama tabii,
şurası deterministlik değil.
Böyle mi olacak?
O deterministlik değil.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
sequential consistency'i anlatmak için,
verilen,
bazı örnek kodlar var.
Başlangıçta karmaşık.
Ama ben,
bir tane,
kendi seçimim,
kodu bulmaya çalışıyorum.
biraz bekleteceğim sizi.
Yani,
şunu göstermek de,
biraz zor olduğu için,
örnekler karmaşık oluyor.
Bütün threadlerin,
aynı sırayla,
gördüğünü,
sequential consistency'de,
aynı sırayla gördüğünü,
göstermek için de,
biraz dikkatli bir örnek,
kurgulamak gerekiyor.
O yüzden,
biraz bekletiyorum sizi.
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın şimdi,
karmaşık örneklerden biri şu.
Bu,
standardın,
kendi verdiği örnek.
Yanlış hatırlamıyorsam.
İzleyin.
Ya bu örneğin,
şimdi üstünden geçmemiz de zor olacak.
Mutlaka,
gitapta,
bir kere bakın.
Çünkü anlatmak da zor,
şey,
anlaşılması da zor.
Arkadaşlar,
burada,
setx isimli bir fonksiyon var.
Sety isimli bir fonksiyon var.
readx deny isimli bir fonksiyon var.
ready denx isimli bir fonksiyon var.
Ve,
bir de,
şu atomik değişkenler var.
Atomic ball,
x flag,
y flag,
atomic int,
y.
Şimdi,
bu fonksiyonların ne yaptığına bakalım.
Setx,
x flag'i,
true değere çekiyor.
Sety,
y flag'i,
true değere çekiyor.
readx deny,
yani,
önce x'i,
sonra y'yi oku.
Önce,
x,
x'i okuyor,
true olduğunu görüyor.
Ondan sonra,
eğer y'yi,
load ettiğinde,
y flag,
o da,
true ise,
burada döngü olmadığına dikkat edin,
ivali bir arttırıyor.
Yani,
burada bir döngü var.
Buradaki döngünün olması ne demek?
Yani,
bu döngüyü geçtikten sonra,
efendim,
x flag'in,
true olduğu,
garanti altında.
Dolayısıyla,
buradaki işlem yapıldığında,
artık x flag'in,
true olma garantisi var,
değil mi?
Evet.
Peki,
x flag,
true olduktan sonra,
aşağıdaki işleme bakın,
y'nin değeri,
true olarak load edilirse,
ivalin değerini bir arttırıyorum.
Burayı anladık mı?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
bu ne demek?
Bakınız,
ben,
bu set x'i,
set y'yi,
read x,
then y'yi çalıştırırsam,
diğer fonksiyon olmasaydı,
burada sequential consistency varsa,
ki,
default,
zaten sequential consistency idi,
şu söz konusu değil mi?
Programın akışı buraya geldiğinde,
zaten,
zaten x'i okumuş olacak,
true olarak,
x'i true olarak okumuş olması demek,
set x'deki bu işlemin,
daha önce yapılması,
ve sonucunun alınması demek,
eğer,
burada da true değer okursa,
izleyin,
o zaman,
burada true değer okunması demek,
set y'de de,
store işleminin,
tamamlanmış olması demek,
ama bakın,
bu false da döndürebilir,
yani,
buradan çıktığında,
y flag,
halen false olabilir,
değil mi?
y flag,
halen false ise,
ibal artmayacak,
buraya kadar anladınız mı?
Evet,
yani,
bu fonksiyon çağrıldığında,
eğer,
bu noktaya geldiğinde,
x flag,
true durumda,
ondan eminiz,
ama y flag,
true durumda,
olmayabilir,
true durumdaysa,
o da ne demek,
set y'deki bu işlem,
daha önce yapılmışsa,
ibalin değeri,
bir artacak.
Ama şimdi,
diğer fonksiyona bakalım,
read y'den x,
burada da tam tersi,
önce y'yi true olarak okuyoruz,
sonra,
x'in,
x flag'in,
x diyorum ben kısaca,
onun değerini yet ediyoruz,
o true ise,
ibali,
bir arttırıyoruz.
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi bakın,
4 thread'i de çalıştırıyorum,
4'ünü de join ediyorum,
funk fonksiyonu içinde.
Soru,
ibalin,
halen sıfır olma ihtimali var mı?
İşte bakın,
sequential consistency'i anlatmak için,
biraz karmaşık olsa da,
her yerde kullanılan,
klasik örnek bu.
Bir düşünün şimdi,
dedim ya,
zihinsel olarak kavramak,
hemen hakim olmak,
biraz zor olabilir.
burada,
funk fonksiyonu çağrıldığında,
ibalin değerinin,
halen sıfır olma ihtimali var mı?
Cevap,
hayır.
Neden?
E çünkü bakın,
eğer,
bu noktaya gelmişse,
zaten,
x flag set edilmiştir.
Dolayısıyla,
y flag'in değeri,
arkadaşlar,
load edildiğinde,
true ise,
ibal artacak.
iki tane ihtimal var.
Ya,
x flag daha önce,
çalışmış olacak.
Yani,
x flag daha önce,
true edilmiş olacak.
Ya da,
y flag.
Öyle değil mi?
Ama,
e zaten,
bu fonksiyonu da,
biri için bekliyoruz.
Bu fonksiyonun içine,
E madem,
sequential consistency,
bütün threadlerin,
aynı sırayı görmesi demekse,
o zaman,
şu garanti altında,
değil mi?
Hangisi daha önce,
çalışırsa çalışsın,
bu durumda,
ikisi de,
aynı total order'ı,
göreceğine göre,
burada,
ibal'in,
artmama ihtimali,
yok.
Dolayısıyla,
buradaki,
assertion'ın,
payl olma ihtimali yok.
İsterseniz,
deneyelim şimdi.
Ama bakın,
nasıl deniyorum,
test koduna da bakın.
10 bin kez deniyorum,
çünkü bir kere tesadüf olabilir,
iki kere tesadüf olabilir.
Şimdi şöyle olsaydı,
öyle bir senaryo olsaydı ki,
buraya geldiğinde,
ibal'in değerinin,
sıfır olması demek,
arkadaşlar,
şuraya,
bu kod da hiç çalışmadı,
ama bu kodlardan,
en az bir tanesi çalışırsa,
ibal'in değerinin,
bir olması demek.
ama bunlar,
aynı sırayı gördüğüne göre,
bu,
böyle bir ihtimal yok.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar,
bakın,
örneğin,
daha da basitleştirilmiş hali,
biraz daha iyi kavrayın diye.
İzleyin.
Şimdi,
ben örneği çok daha basit hale getirdim,
en azından bir garantiyi görmeniz için.
Burada,
bütün store işlemleri,
ve load işlemleri,
memory order,
sequential consistent,
bellek düzeninde yapılıyor ki,
zaten bu argümanları koymasaydım,
default,
öyle olacaktı,
dikkat çeksin diye böyle yazdım.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi,
uyu ve barı ayrı threadlerde çalıştıracağım.
Yavaş yavaş takip etmeye çalışın.
O zaman,
az önceki,
benim gösterdiğim resmi hatırlayın.
Hatta o resme geri dönelim.
Dört tane işlem var ya,
şu sıradan,
herhangi birinde olmak zorunda değil mi?
Ama,
ikisi de aynı sırayı görecek değil mi?
Şimdi koda bakın,
buradaki işlemde,
önce x'i set ettim.
Yani x'i bir yaptım.
Ondan sonra,
y'nin değerini r1'e okudum.
Diğer fonksiyonda ise,
bar fonksiyonda ise,
önce y'nin değerini bir okudum.
Bir olarak set ettim.
Sonra,
x'in değerini,
arkadaşlar,
okudum.
Yani okudum derken,
o load işlemlerinin,
geri dönüş değerini,
r1 ve r2 değişkenlerine yazdım.
Şimdi soru,
x'in değeri sıfır,
y'nin değeri sıfır.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Ve,
iki thread'i çalıştırıyorum.
Burada,
r1'in ve r2'nin,
ikisinin birden sıfır olma ihtimali var mı?
Bir düşünün.
İkisinin birden sıfır olma ihtimali var mı?
Cevap,
buradaki sıra,
kendi içinde değişmeyecek.
Yani,
az önceki kombinasyonlardan,
hangisi olursa olsun,
bu işlem,
bu işlemden,
önce yapılacak.
Bu işlem de,
bu işlemden önce yapılacak.
Buraya kadar takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Ama,
ikisi de aynı sırayı görecek.
O zaman,
oluşabilecek bütün kombinasyonlara var.
bakın.
Mesela,
doğrudan bu sırayla olsaydı,
yani,
önce bir,
sonra iki,
sonra üç,
sonra dört.
O zaman,
x'in değerini bir yapacaktı.
r1'in,
değeri sıfır olacaktı.
Çünkü,
y daha set edilmedi.
y'nin değeri,
bir olacak.
ama burada arkadaşlar,
r2 eşittir.
x,
daha önce set edildiğine göre,
1 olacak.
Yani,
özür dilerim,
r2,
1 olacak.
Yani,
bakın,
bu kombinasyonlardan,
hangisini seçerseniz,
seçin.
İkisi de,
aynı sırayı gördüğüne göre,
total bir order olduğuna göre,
istediğiniz kombinasyonu,
seçin.
mutlaka hiçbir şekilde,
hem x'in,
hem y'nin,
ne olma ihtimali yok.
Sıfır olma,
ihtimali yok.
İkisinde,
ikisinde de,
her seferinde,
bir yazmasını istersek,
ne yapmalıyız?
Arkadaşlar,
örneği yanlış anlamış olabilirsiniz.
Bu örnek,
neyi göstermeye,
bir şey yapmayı,
hedeflemiyor.
Bu örnek,
sequential consistency'nin,
neyi sağladığını anlatıyor.
Yani,
burada örneğin,
memori düzeni,
sequential consistency olmasaydı,
deneyip çalıştırıyorum.
Mesela,
şöyle olsaydı,
memori order,
arkadaşlar,
bırakın,
sequential consistency'yi,
bakın bunları,
acquire yapsaydım,
release yapsaydım.
Memori order,
release,
memori order,
acquire,
release,
memori order,
acquire,
arkadaşlar,
bu arada,
şu da yanıtıyor.
yani,
şimdi testte,
assertion fail olmadı demeniz,
bu garantinin olduğu anlamına gelmiyor.
Çünkü,
tamamen,
terleyici tarafında,
ya da işlemci tarafında,
yapılan optimizasyonlara bağlı.
şimdi artık,
bu seçeneklerden biri olmak zorunda değil.
Reordering de olabilir.
Reordering,
yeniden sıralama,
derlecinin yaptığı optimizasyonda olabilir,
işlemci tarafında olabilir.
Yani,
bu total order garantisi,
verilmiyor.
işlemlerin sonucunun,
birbiri tarafından görülebileceği,
verilmiyor.
Yani,
böyle olması,
bunun bir garanti altında olması demek değil.
Tabi,
arada başka kodlar,
bunlar olsaydı,
belki onu,
doğrudan,
gözlemleme şansına da sahip olacaktık.
Arkadaşlar,
şimdi kursla ilgili,
genel bir takım notlar,
ve ondan sonra,
biraz diğer C++ kursundan bahsedeceğim.
Şimdi,
bir,
bazı konular,
C++ o kadar büyük bir programlama değil ki,
iki üç saate her şeye sığdırmak mümkün değil.
Mesela,
bu,
concurrency konusunda,
eksik kalan yerler var.
Mesela,
semafor,
binary,
counting semafor,
binary semafor,
latchler,
daha önemlisi,
bu,
paralel algoritmalar.
Ama şimdi,
zamanda azaldığı için,
onlara ayrı bir ders yapıp,
ekleyeceğim.
En azından,
paralel algoritmalar,
konusu,
ve semafor konusu,
bunlar önemli.
Çünkü,
semaforlar da çok kullanılıyor.
Onun dışında,
bu kursda,
ele almadığımız,
ama üretimde,
önemli olan,
standart kütüphane üyelerini,
ileri C++ kursunda anlatıyorum.
Yine aynı şekilde,
o kursun içeriğine bakarsanız,
orada,
yine bu kursa anlatmadığımız,
C++ 20 ile gelen,
önemli araçları,
mesela,
onlar da böyle çok,
bir saatte,
iki saatte,
anlaşılacak konular değil.
Örneğin,
Ranges kütüphanesini,
ki,
popüler olarak,
STL 2.0 diyorlar artık.
Ranges kütüphanesindeki üyeleri,
Ranges kütüphanesinin,
kullanılması,
konseptler,
konseptlerin kullanılması,
ki bunlar birbirleriyle,
ilişkili halde de kullanılıyor.
Efendim,
korutinler,
korutinlerin kullanılması,
bir kere,
C++ 20 ile gelen,
bu önemli araçlar,
o kursun konusu.
Burada,
anlatmadığımız,
zaman kalmayan,
jenerik programlamayla ilgili,
bazı konular,
burada zaman yetmediği için,
mesela az önce bir tanesini söyleyeyim,
deduction guides'a,
hiç değinmedim.
Yine,
bunun dışında,
şöyle bir hatırlamaya çalışayım,
evet,
ideomlar ve teknikler,
bence en önemli kısmı bu.
Yani,
üretimde,
C++ programcılık,
çok sık kullandığı,
ideomlar ve teknikler,
görmediğimiz bazı sınıflar,
mesela,
Regex'e hiç değinmedim.
Bazı kurslarda,
vakit yetiyor,
anlatıyorum,
bazılarında yetmiyor.
Regex,
her programcının,
bilmesi gereken bir konu.
Hem Regex,
notasyonunu anlatıyorum,
tipik bir Regex,
notasyonunu,
hem de,
C++'a,
standart kütüphanesindeki,
arkadaşlar,
Regex ile ilişkin,
öğeleri anlatıyorum.
onun dışında,
stud yine çok önemli,
stud format kütüphanesi,
efendim,
yani,
bu kursta olmayan,
ama,
C++ 20 ile gelen,
önemli öğeler,
bilir,
C++ kursunda anlatılıyor.
Ama onun dışında,
dediğim gibi,
videomlar,
teknikler,
işte bu taşıma semantiği ile ilgili,
daha detaylı,
konuların incelenmesi,
Perfect Boarding,
Moo Semantics vs.
bunlardan faydalanmak,
maalesef o kursta katılıyor.
Ama,
söz vermemekle beraber,
buraya,
bir,
iki,
maksimum,
üç ders daha ekleyebilirim,
ama onlar canlı olmayacak.
Yani,
onları kayıt olarak yükleyeceğim.
Telegram grubunu,
bir anı bir süre,
açık tutacağım.
Hatta hiç kapatmıyorum.
Yani,
kurs bittikten sonra da,
Telegram grubu üstünden,
soru sorabilirsiniz.
Hocam,
bundan sonra,
hangi kitapları okumalıyız,
sırayla söyleyebilir misiniz?
Nereden,
testler işleyelim?
Hangi,
platformu,
ya da kitapları önersiniz?
Bunların hepsini,
Resul,
Telegram grubunda,
bana sorun.
Orada,
şimdi,
çünkü,
kitap isimleri,
hemen aklıma gelmeyebilir.
Ya da sırasını,
kafamda heyecanlandıramayabilirim.
Ama özellikle,
bu kurs bittikten sonra,
artık temel kurs bittikten sonra,
daha ilerlemek için,
neler yapabilirsiniz?
Onları,
açıklarım olur mu?
En azından,
kendi fikrimi söylerim.
Nasıl ilerlemek daha kolay?
Evet,
ondan sonra,
başka,
neleri söylemek istiyorum?
bu en çok sorulan sorulardan biri,
kurs kayıtlarının,
hangi sürece,
arkadaşlar,
açık kalacağı?
Şimdi,
Temmuz ayında başladı,
çok uzun sürdü,
haftada iki gün olduğu için,
şu anda,
Şubat ayı bitti.
Yani,
Temmuz,
Ağustos,
Eylül,
Ekim,
Kasım,
Aralık,
Ocak,
Şubat,
şimdi,
Mart'ta geleceğiz.
Bu da ne demek?
7 aya yakın,
kurs sürmüş.
Tabi,
bütün arkadaşların,
bütün dersleri izlediğini,
düşünemiyoruz.
O yüzden,
dersleri tamamlamamış,
arkadaşlar olabilir.
Normalde bizim kuralımız şu,
kurumun kuralı,
kurs bittikten sonra,
3 ay boyunca,
erişime açık.
Ama kesinlikle ve kesinlikle,
arkadaşlar,
kopyalanmaması,
ve başkalarıyla paylaşılmaması gerekiyor.
Diyelim ki,
o 3 ay bitti.
fakat siz,
yani kendiniz tekrar etmek,
ya da dinlemediğiniz,
bitiremediğiniz dersler olabilir.
O zaman bana yazarsanız,
ben yine erişim hakkı veriyorum.
Yani orada bir sıkıntı çıkacağını zannetmiyorum.
Herhangi bir kötü niyet olmadığı sürece,
tabi ki amacımız,
isteğimiz herkesin,
kursu bitirmiş olması.
Bütün dersleri izleyen arkadaşlar,
sertifika için,
başvurabilirler.
doğrudan bana yazabilirsiniz.
Yani bütün dersleri bitirdiğinizi,
kişisel beyanda bulunursanız,
onlar hemen,
bu katılım sertifikasını da,
arkadaşlara iletiriz.
Telegram üstünde.
Mehmet Ali İkici,
C++ networkingle ilgili bir library ya da spesifikasyon var mı?
Bu konuya dair bir dersiniz var mı?
Arkadaşlar,
bu konuya dair kurs kapsamında bir dersim yok.
Networking standart değil.
Şimdi en çok tartışılan konulardan biri bu.
Sürekli de bu standart toplantılarında,
komiklerinde konuşuluyor.
Hazır çalışma grubu var,
şu var,
bu var.
İşte C++,
daha 20'ye bile yetişmesi söz konusuydu.
En azından onun konuşması yapılıyordu.
20 geçti,
23 geçti.
Şimdi 26 artık sonuçlanmaya çok yakın.
Ama halen networking ne değil?
Arkadaşlar,
standart kütüphanenin bir parçası değil.
Networkingle ilgili kullanılan ana kütüphane,
arkadaşlar,
Boost'un SEO'su.
Yani asla şunu bile yapsalar,
büyük iyilik yapmış olacaklar.
Boost SEO'yu standart kütüphanenin bir bileşeni yapsalar.
Arkadaşlar,
bu arada tabii bu kursta doğal olarak
Boost'tan da hiç bahsetmedim.
Boost adeta standart kütüphanenin bir devamı gibi.
Zaten standart kütüphanedeki bazı öğeler,
tamamen Boost'tan alınma küçük değişikliklerle.
Yani örneğin,
Studeray daha önce Boost'ta vardı,
Studeray'ın Boost'ta vardı.
Boost'ta olan,
C++'ın standart kütüphanesinde olmayan,
örneğin konteynerler var.
Template meta programlamaya ilişkin çok güzel araçlar var.
Dolayısıyla,
üretimde büyük ihtimalle,
ya zaten kullanmışsınızdır Boost'un herhangi bir alt kütüphanesini,
ya da ileride kullanacak olabilirsiniz.
Tekrar bu networking konusuna gelecek olursak,
C++'da networking standart değil.
Ya Boost SEO kullanıyor,
ne yapmak istediğinize bağlı olarak.
Ama Boost SEO'da çok büyük bir kütüphane,
biraz da karmaşık olduğu için,
çünkü tamamen template bazlı,
zaten biliyorsunuz networking konusu yeterince karmaşık.
O yüzden bu SEO'yu sarmalayan,
daha light kütüphaneler var.
Onlar da yine,
bunların hemen hepsi,
arkadaşlar,
header only library'ler.
Mesela Boost Beast diye bir kütüphane var.
Yine Boost,
ama bu SEO'nun biraz daha kolay kullanılan hale getirilmiş biçimi,
o Boost Beast'i de kullanabilirsiniz.
Ama tabii bunun dışında başka networking kütüphaneleri de mutlaka var.
Ama Boost hemen hemen neredeyse standart gibi arkadaşlar algılanıyor.
Rasul Mehmetov,
hocam öncelikle teşekkür ederim,
ben teşekkür ederim derslere katıldığınız için.
Tüm dersleri izledim,
buradaki arkadaşların çoğu programlamadan gelenler,
ama bende domen farklıydı.
İlk defa bir programlama dilini bu kadar iyi öğrendim sonunda.
Aslında ilk defa programlamaya tanışmışsanız,
C++'da başlamak,
hani İngilizcesi de çok büyük bir challenge.
Yani programlamada,
bakın mesela bu birçok yerde tartışılan konu,
programlamaya C++'da başlamak,
birçok kişinin motivasyonunu
programlama dilleri.
Mesela C onun için çok uygun.
Ya da fonksiyonel programlama dillerinden Python uygun.
NS önemli programlama dillerinden Java çok uygun.
Mesela Java ile başlasaydınız,
büyük ihtimalle daha ne bileyim,
daha kolay ilerlerdiniz,
daha hızlı giderdiniz.
Belki zorlandığınız yerler daha az olurdu.
Evet.
Secure Code Review ile ilgili neler önerebilirsiniz?
Onunla ilgili kitapları da paylaşabilir misiniz?
Arkadaşlar şimdi bu Code Review konusu da,
hatta ben bu ileri C++ kursuna,
iyi ki hatırlattınız,
onu da alacağım.
Yani 3-4 tane projeyi Code Review yapacağım,
arkadaşlarla birlikte canlı olarak.
Yani burada bu neden kötü,
bu neden iyi?
Onları kursa eklemeyi düşünüyorum.
Alihan, emeğiniz büyük.
Sizinle tanışmadan önce bir Türkçe kaynak olarak da,
C++'da bu kadar ilerleyeceğimi bilemezdim.
Teşekkür ederim, çok naziksiniz.
Evet, bu Code Review'yu,
C++, ileri C++ kursuna ekleyelim.
Arkadaşlar çünkü gerçekten benim gözlemim şu,
ben şimdi hem Türkiye'de hem yurt dışında
bazı şirketlere Code Review hizmeti de veriyorum.
Şu anda azaldı biraz ama geçmişte çok verdim.
Yani üretimde böyle kullanıcı gözüyle baktığınızda
dehşet verici projeler,
neler yapıyor bu program falan dediğiniz projelerin
kodlarına baktığınızda
kod kalitesinin çok iyi olmadığını görüyorsunuz.
Gerçekten, mesela şimdi ben firma ismi de vermeyeyim.
Bir firmanın kodlarına bakıyoruz.
Ya yapay zekayla görüntü işlemeyi öyle bir birleştirmişler ki,
zaten ekipte çalışanların hepsi
uzmanlığı yapay zeka olan kişiler.
Yani C++ birinci bir şeyleri değil, ne diyelim.
Birinci bir uzmanlık alanları değil.
Ya program çalışıyor.
Çalışan programa baksanız gerçekten böyle hayran oluyorsunuz.
Ya görüntüyü yakalıyor,
oradan yapay zekayı kullanıyor,
analiz yapıyor vesaire.
Ama koda baktığınızda kodlar o kadar kötü C++ kodu ki,
e şimdi üretimde C++'ı böyle kullananlar çoğunlukta.
Yani sonuç odaklı.
Ben kısa sürede işimi bitireyim,
çalışan bir ürün olsun,
müşteriye zamanında yetişsin.
Ama ondan sonraki süreç,
tabii biraz problemli olacak.
O kodlara bir ekleme yapmak istediğinizde,
orada bug aradığınızda falan işiniz çok zor olacak.
O da başlangıçta kişilerin birinci kaygısı olmuyor.
Tabii ki çok düzgün, çok iyi,
kaliteli kod yazan firmalar da çok.
Ama ortalama biraz kalite düşüktüğü tarafında.
Çünkü C++'ı da işte görüyorsunuz,
o kadar araç, o kadar fazla,
kütüphane öğesi,
farklı programlama paradigmaları bir arada kullanılıyor.
Fonksiyonel programlama,
nesne yönelimli programlama,
jenerik programlama.
Dolayısıyla bütün bunları zaten öğrenmek bir zaman oluyor.
Standart kütüphaneyi öğrenmek bir zaman oluyor.
Ve insanlar niye de çok fazla zaman ayırmıyorlar?
İyi kod nedir?
Kötü kod nedir?
Önemli olan işini görmesi.
Bu anlayış çok yaygın.
Ama tabii bu anlayışın hakim olmadığı firmalarda var.
Evet arkadaşlar bugün 10 dakika erken bitireceğim.
Deniz Akkuş.
İnsan olarak çok şık birisiniz.
Ben çok teşekkür ediyorum.
4-5 ders kaçırmışımdır.
Ama her dersinize zevkle ve canlı izletebilecek yetkinlikte
ve yetkinlikte biri olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.
Arkadaşlar nazik sözleriniz için çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Bir soru daha var.
Onu da cevap vereyim.
Ona da cevap vereyim.
Soruyu okumuyorum.
Soru biraz uzun.
Ama zaten cevabımı verirken sorunun ne olduğu anlaşılacak.
Şimdi arkadaşlar,
üretimde en önemli konulardan biri de
üretimde çalışan kişi açısından bakarsak tool'lar.
Fakat tool'ları ben genel olarak C++ kurslarına almıyorum.
İki nedenden almıyorum.
Bir, arkadaşlar çok fazla zaman gidiyor.
Bir de tool anlatmayı ben sevmiyorum.
Yani bana uygun bir konu değil.
Yani mesela şimdi bazen arkadaşlar rica ediyor C kursunda bu Visual Studio ID'sini anlatır mısın?
Başkasının yazdığı, geliştirdiği programın anlatmak bana çok iyi bir fikir gelmiyor.
Bir de zaten bu seviyeye gelmiş arkadaşlar.
Bu tool'ları kendileri de öğrenebiliyorlar.
Belki şu eklenebilir.
Yani bir tool'un kendisini öğretmek yerine genel olarak tool kategorileri neler yapıyor?
Onların önemi ne?
Yani mesela sanitizer ne demek?
Hangi sanitizer olduğundan bağımsız olarak?
Efendim ya da statik kod analizi dediğimiz programlar ne yapıyor?
Profiler programlar ne yapıyor?
Üretimde neden önemli?
Build tool'ları neden önemli?
Vesaire ama şimdilik tool'ların kendisini anlatmak çok bana uygun bir iş değil.
Belki gerekiyor olabilir.
Hatta şunu bile düşünüyorum.
Bundan sonraki kursları bu tool'ları da iyi anlatan başka bir arkadaşımdan rica etsem
böyle efendim Google testi, şunu bunu, sanitizer'ları, Walgreens'i, şunu bunu anlatsa iyi olur aslında.
Ama benim burada birinci tercihim önce C++ dili, programlama tarafı, iyi kod, kötü kod tarafı ki
ileri C++ kursunda onlara daha fazla değineceğim.
Peki o zaman ben de kursa katılan herkese çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Dediğim gibi halen Telegram grubundan sorularınızı sorabilirsiniz.
Arkadaşlar bazen mesajları kaçırıyorum.
İnsanlık hali çok sizin gibi ben de çok yoğun çalıştığım için.
Arkadaşlar da alınganlık gösteriyorlar.
Yani sanki ben kasti olarak cevap vermemişim gibi.
O yüzden derslerde en az bir iki kere söylüyorum.
Eğer bana bir mesaj yazmışsanız Telegram üstünde WhatsApp'tan ya da LinkedIn'den bir cevap alamamışsanız
lütfen lütfen lütfen lütfen bir daha hani ayıp olur mu falan diye de düşünmeyin.
Tekrar yazın.
Yani belirli bir süre, makul bir süre içinde cevap vermemişsem onu atlamışım demektir.
Dolayısıyla tekrar bana hatırlatırsanız o zaman mutlaka cevap veririm.
Evet.
Herkese iyi akşamlar diliyorum.
Hayırlı Ramazanlar diliyorum arkadaşlar.
İnşallah bazı arkadaşlarla belki ileri C++ kursunda da birlikte olacağız.
Eğer bu 200 saat sizi yeteri kadar yormadıysa o zaman orada görüşeceğiz.
Hoşçakalın.
Altyazı M.K.